ça semble être en retard il ya des
caméras qui ont disparu elles ont pas
réapparu je vais tout régler et on a
faim c'est pas vraiment été pris de
vitesse c'est plus que il est en
préparation et tout d'un coup en fait on
sait pas pourquoi ça ont commencé quand
la maman en a l'air bon c'est une
variante classé pour le moment h35 et
qu'elle court va choisir donc y est les
blancs parce que kevin il faut que tu
m'aides chez les blancs série fans
attend là j'ai mis un petit mais c'était
c'était volontaire c'était pour que tu
puisse voir les caméras en avant match
en fait parce que d'habitude quand
j'arrive que l'écran tu les vois pas et
c'était juste pour te montrer les
joueuses quoi en vrai que j'ai fait je
connais où il fait des pc longtemps j'ai
la ligue chinoise laquelle dans la même
équipe quand elle avait dix ans à 10 ans
je regardais c'est parti je me disais
mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils bonjour
première le chéquier je veux traiter une
petite anecdote sur vladou quand elle
avait 14 ou 15 ans vlad m'a dit va
falloir vraiment que je réfléchisse à
prendre ma retraite parce que maintenant
on aime une petite fille de 14 ans tu me
battre c'est vrai elle avait des parties
est tellement bien construite
c'était vraiment impressionnant et j'ai
aussi discuté avec ses jeans à l'époque
l'ancien champion du monde jacques est
un cas consacrer aussi sa vie à
l'éducation donc des échecs
il disait que ce sera la future
championne du monde et c'est toujours la
meilleure joueuse du monde maintenant il
est devenu professeur d'université je
crois à shenzhen non oui oui j'ai
discuté avec elle parce qu'on discute de
temps en temps et
me parlait beaucoup de ces études de ses
choix parce que l époque l moi même ma
demande des conseils s'il devait suivre
tu vois si parcours académique que je le
dis que mon plus grand regret c'est de
ne pas le signer et l'a fini à
l'université d'oxford et après oui mais
l'enseigne jeune scène c'est le plus
jeune professeur de tous les temps je
crois mais l'ol doit être vraiment
incroyable j malheureusement jamais eu
la chance de discuter avec elle mais
j'imagine que ça va être une personne
absolument incroyable oui fans est
tellement calme a posé pour ces
adorables en même temps quand elle ce
soit sur l'échiquier je me souviens de
notre dernière sortie grand prix de
monaco
c'était un vrai thriller je pouvais même
la gagne et je me disais est ce que je
fais nul ou est ce que je gagne à la fin
de ce que je tente de la gagner mais
bien évidemment je pourrait la perdre
mais je me dis qu'il va se souvenir de 7
nuls et je vais essayer de la gagner et
yngwie du coup tu ne le connaît bien ou
pas j'ai l'impression qu'on y voit plus
rarement en europe non mais déjà c'est
une joueuse beaucoup mon plus jeune âge
il ne joue pas du tout un héros que je
croyais je fais très peu de tournois
elle participe régulièrement à des
tournois officiels
c'est une très bonne joueuse de blitz
est ce que je sais il a donc trois gars
trois ans d'écart elle a l'air très
posée aussi non elle n'a pas l'air
tueuse entre guillemets tu vois là la
reposer tranquille aussi un peu comme
willy fans toutes les deux elles ont
elles ont cette attitude un peu way est
posée je dirais oui mais c'est tellement
propre chinois je pense tu sais je n'ai
alors ma part va au kelenn personnel
était bon pour un joueur chinois
excentrique il n'hésite pas à donner son
avis au système il est extrêmement drôle
tu sais les joueurs chinois elle sent
que tout réservé à la toiture toi qui
fais souvent les interviews au
grand-duché tour et cetera pour moi
dingli règne c'est une très grande
interrogation parce que il a l'air
tellement gentil il a l'air tellement
réservé est gentil et et et de haut
niveau c'est vraiment une anomalie entre
guillemets les joueurs sont plutôt
s'extériorise et tu as l'impression
qu'ils ont un égo on va pas dire
surdimensionné mais qu'ils ont leur
petit ego à se penser plus fort que les
autres et c'est normal c'est propre à
tous les grands sportifs et à tous le
tout ce duo nous tous les tous les
joueurs du haut niveau quel que soit le
sport mais genre sont dignes biren lui
il s'inscrit en porte-à-faux par rapport
à ça ah oui tu as tout à fait raison je
me souviens de cette dernière interview
à saint louis qui nous a accordé du coup
quand elle a battu magnus carlsen dans
un tie break up cela m'en fous et même
après cette victoire presque historique
et en plus ils avaient vraiment dominé
indigne ce n'est pas un coup de bol ou
une partie qui a bien tourné la juste
vraiment mieux jouer proprement gagné
web et donc il
il n'arrivait même pas à exprimer sa
joie ça c'est déjà les avis de son
adversaire qui s'était c'était
extraordinaire parce que tu sais on
essaie toujours c'est ça mon éthique on
essaie toujours de préserver
l'adversaire de ne pas le faire souffrir
en opération sur le moment donné et je
lui ai posé la question tout simplement
mais quelle sera la fête à l'heure
non mais peut-être qu'on fera quelque
chose dans ma chambre avec mes amis un
tout petit peu voilà tous très délicat
sur le sujet aa c'est incroyable c'est
une autre une autre mentalité une autre
manière d'approcher le sport j'ai
l'impression vraiment oui mais en même
temps ça me rappelle aussi maxime g
c'est maxime qui est une personne
extrêmement il est d'une élégance très
rare oui dans son attitude inverse à ses
collègues et dans ses commentaires et
tout simplement sonnette valais ils ont
tous les deux cette délicatesse qu'est
ce que tu penses que c'est quelque chose
qui peut manquer un maxime justement toi
qui es qui a aussi été une grande
joueuse et dans les meilleures mondiales
que tu penses que ce côté un peu méchant
voire même parfois arrogant ça peut ça
peut apporter quelque chose finalement 1
sur une question difficile un évidemment
difficile a fait ce dieu sait comment
mais l'a soutenu et
surtout qu'on ne sait pas si tu as vu le
documentaire je vous conseille vivement
de le regarder il vient de sortir sur
kasparov pièce six mois la trace le
parcours de maxime de secret c'est tout
à fait possible que que ce côté de
l'école la pêche et peut-être aussi pas
tant qu'êtres humains mais aussi dans
son approche
tu vois dans sa préparation et il reste
fidèle à ses convictions
à chaque fois donc je veux toujours les
mêmes ouverture et on l'a évoqué qui
devient une cible facile non d'un très
grand niveau et bien sûr il les connaît
ses positions par coeur mais les
analyses évolue tellement vite il suffit
d'une soirée pour trouver parfois
bouleverser toute la ligne lee c'est un
joueur extraordinaire et mais je pense
que peut-être une certaine notion de
sacrifice et lui manque sacrifices dans
le sens qu'il faut passer par la doller
pour attendre le titre après je ne sais
pas si je te rejoins complètement là
dessus sans langue de bois j'ai toujours
eu cette impression c'est peut-être
parce que tu vas toi tu as ta cette
école soviétique moi j'ai vécu longtemps
en russie et c'est vrai que ça m'a
forcément influencé aussi mais tata
cette impression à un moment donné qu'il
faut se faire mal et faire mal aux
autres en fait c'est vrai comme tu le
dit de passer par la douleur soit même
aidé en infliger aux autres en fait pas
vraiment ce côté là j'ai l'impression et
j'ai l'impression que magnus là et que
c'est quelque chose d'assez important
pour réussir au sport de haut niveau et
c'est vrai que les joueurs que l'on
parle de maxime et les joueurs chinois
tu as l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas trop
ce truc là non plus non parce que je me
suis posé cette question là et je pense
que c'est pas si évident quant à dire en
fait c'étaient des là nous renvoie notre
condition animale
on n'accepte pas forcément et photos je
le sais personnellement je l'acceptais
pagé
j'ai du mal de gens voulaient comment
fléché la souffrance alors par contre
j'ai sacrifié mourir sur l'échiquier ça
je le comprends parce que ça fait partie
de l'éducation c'est ça va cesser c'est
justement au nom du cétacé dit cette
éducation entre guillemets russe ou
soviétique ou quand même tenté côté tout
et on a pris enfin ils ont appris que ça
marchait comme ça et que ça pouvait pas
marcher autrement quoi oui disons qu'on
a été conditionné c'est une façon encore
un fois de percevoir le sport c'était
tout un système
il est je pense que le modèle chinois
auraient pris quelque part cet
enseignement de qualité qu'ils ont
reproduit même si parfois elles allaient
très joué sélection toujours les
meilleurs joueurs dans les écoles depuis
leur jeune âge et j'ai donné quelques
simultanées contre les meilleurs jeunes
dans la chine une anecdote absolument
époustouflante c'est que à 9 heures du
matin évidente est tellement fatigue et
a dormi deux heures et il joue contre
les champions de chine dans toute leur
catégorie et il ya un jeune garçon de 10
ans que s'est distingué parmi les autres
et je vais très très bien et je me suis
dit bon il faudrait que je fasse nul que
je répète les coûts sur cet échec est là
parce que comme ça ça me faciliterait
aussi massive et de la simultanée et
donc j'ai commencé à répéter les coups
et le garçon est évidemment il répète le
coup parce qu'il va faire un match nul
avec un grand m à 10 ans je me suis bien
moi même ce que c'était de la personne
rien que d'apercevoir un grand m c'était
un rêve et il leur vient son entraîneur
qui commence à hurler en anglais en
chinois ça durait cinq minutes et tu
comprends très bien qui lui a donné les
consignes qu'il n'est pas venu ici pour
faire match nul
on doit se battre et ils aiment moins il
a perdu la partie mais
voilà sept cet épisode la main beaucoup
marqué ouais mais bon à la dure quoi et
finalement est-ce que c'est pas c'est
pas bien quelque part je sais pas pour
devenir fort c'est comme ça juste que
j'étais je suis intrigué par la finale
une petite seconde sa ma la position m'a
coupé dans notre conversation et je me
suis dit c'est peut-être une partie
parfaitement et qu'il est vrai et la
finale
je priais la gagner un temps fou ifaw
elle va gagner l'amour et la passion est
la seule chance pour tenter quelque
chose ça aurait été de gagner les trois
pions et de rester avec les quatre pions
mais je sais c'est que rien ou ce
qu'elle a fait dans l'erreur des 6 et où
on l'a raté complètement bas ont regardé
ouais moi vu ce tu vois je te couper pas
pour aller sur la partie parce que je me
disais ça a l'air d'aller vers une nulle
tranquille doit également ces biens et
puis tout d'un coup
ouais le fou est passé du rsa le dtp
tout en gagnant en fait cette finale qui
sait oui bonjour tout le monde de
l'image qu'avait de m'a dit qu'il va à
s'est enrayé le chat
ouais je suis envoyé un petit peu mais
là je pense était c'était sympa
on était on est parti sur un sujet très
intéressant et de tu vois le chat un
taux si je la fis chaoui est écrit en
guise et c'est malheureusement et tout
ce qui est écrit un peu pitié que les
chiffres qui montrent le ton s'est déjà
oui il faut continuer comme ça tu vois
bien j'ai un peu plus ce que je vois les
les chiffres là je le vois alors qu'est
ce que c'était c'était leur l'erreur 0
la nage des finances était la nage
d'abord oui
l'agent structure chez venin gars
attention pour tim j 1 qui perd déjà la
première partie eux parce que comme je
te le disais hier j'imagine qui a
forcément un impact psychologique de
willy fans sur les autres joueuses
chinoises un kamal est même largement
plus forte que les autres et qu'elle a
dû les battre à plusieurs reprises et je
pense que si le score commence à enfler
admira ça peut ça peut très mal tourner
très très vite pour team gym c'est vrai
là j'ai regardé un fan je sais pas
pourquoi déjà il a choisi le nageur
contre les fidji peut-être qu'elle veut
s'amuser aussi un oui fallait le voir
plus trop et peut-être qu'elle a envie
de se faire plaisir sur un événement
comme ça mais en l appel n'avait pas
joué de sa voiture classique comme la
rouille ou pèse donc on va voir
oui ce sont des parties et est l'un des
deux hommes cédric avait pas ce que fait
2 fois 3 avec à trois jours a dit que
j'aurais économiser sur fouet deux jours
je vais dame de 9,3 tout de suite donc
elle elle veut jouer avec f4 et f5 après
ça dépend encore une fois je me dis si
les hommes si les noirs ok c est ce que
je peux prendre un cc jouer j'ai 4 4
pour éviter ce plan là elle va prendre
et rauque et probablement et sinon jobé
5 elle veut retarder leur route le plus
longtemps possible
c'est tout à fait possible et oui parce
que
avec g4 m'a l'air très dangereux mais b5
forêt c'est tu vois ici je me suis posé
la question est ce que tu fais les
grands en europe quand même donc
probablement yoga en route mais les deux
sont possibles
moi je serais plutôt petit rock mais
parce que j'attaque mais je me suis dit
est ce que c'est de la plage je crois
mais les rockets
non c'est sûrement bon justice
généralement j'ai peur mais ça c'est un
ça peut être un défaut mais dès que j'ai
touché un pion devant le droit je me
sens mal à l'aise
c'est pour ça que je trouve cet ordre de
cours à curieux peut-être proposé par le
redis je ne suis pas du tout et ça j'ai
pas du tout analysé cette ligne je
préfère avant le pion à deux états tout
en vain clairement oui je te comprends
tandis que là je pense c'est l'euro qui
se sera g4 donc il faut faire quelque
chose
le plan typique je sais quand on prend
des quatre c'est de jouer ou 5
bien évidemment pour cibler la case de 5
je sais pas si c'est nécessaire ici
souvent quand tu prends qu'elle ait des
quatre fois des captures joué cinq tout
de suite donc elle a préféré djembé 5-fu
baisse est quand même fait rock les cg
quatre arrivées et puis tant pis on part
avec lecavalier ont bien verbe et 6 à 4
ou c5
de toute façon ça va partir
quand même c'était sûr mais il y tombe
combien de coups avec les blancs light
mcquaid donc un deux trois quatre
voiliers tu vas qu'elle est 17e fête
tout à fait raison et donc là il faut
oui c'est ça ce sont les plantes
typiques pour cette position là ce qui
est intéressant d'ailleurs pour cette
partie qu on va suivre
comment il faut jouer avec les blancs et
comment il faut jouer les deux noix h 4g
5h05 g6v ce serait le plan typique aussi
mais en même temps je me suis posé la
question h4 est ce que je ressens 5
ça c'est bon j'ai l'impression que les
noirs finalement s'en sortent pas mal à
l'émirat
enfin je veux dire c'est tendu mais j'ai
l'impression que ça va aussi assez vite
côté noir
oui je suis d'accord les files c'est
pour ça que je suis sûrement se poser la
question sur le coût à 3 à sa part être
un coup en trop oui c'est passé
actuellement elle l'a fait at en chef au
septième coup après aussi ça l'a
immédiatement fait à trois ça ne paraît
pas bizarre si ça me paraît bizarre mais
bon voilà c'est certes une seconde et un
centième donc je me dis elle devait
connaître ainsi à la joue et argo roye b
mais du coup maintenant cavalier va
arriver vers ses cafés puis descend ça
je ne comprends pas la sq les remet en
les noirs sont mais pour moi les
bécistes qui avait laissé quatre et des
5 vous prendra trois ou quoi ça va quand
même très vite ans parce que sky c4
arrive sur tempo des cinq ça arrive sur
tempo il ya tour ses huit ouais je suis
d'accord réguler et le fou en f3 n'a pas
si bien placé ses six essais c'est un
autre plan que tu utilises dans la neige
d'or faut faire pour jouer à 5 se
protègent le plan toujours poussé six
daims bessette parfois ou fausse et 6 à
5 b 4 c cet implant typique des joueurs
de neige losc français transpose dans ce
genre de structure dans la structure de
base clients comme on évite donc je vous
fais deux top-5 du jury six des sept
noms comme tu le disais vous protéger et
attaquer oui oui c'est tout à qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait l'effet d'un vendeur dans
me2 oui et l'empêchent à 5 pour le
moment donc tout à fait dans le b 7 avec
les dettes jeu à cinq qui je me pose
encore une fois la question si eux
s'inquiètent toujours possible tu vois
on n'a pas envie et d'affaiblir la casse
de 5 mais en même temps on force les
changes et le cas bel et bien c'est
quand même fou 3 qui prend la f4 et je
joue cavalier 5 que ce fou enlève 3
et clairement il faut que tu sais ça va
bien pour les noirs en russie qui va
peut-être arriver un jour sur m6 si on y
arrive suite j'ai six couches 17 qui va
taper là dedans et non ça ça fait jouer
après ça c'est un truc que je dis
souvent quand je regarde parfois compter
mieux en blitz ya qu une seule manière
de se retrouver mal c'est d'utiliser
trop de temps et c'est peut-être ce que
fait oui fans ici par mon encore que ça
va il lui reste une 05 elle gère mais tu
vois tout rabais huit dames bessette
c'est pas des coups qui ont entre c'est
pas des coups qui coûtera 2,5 très bien
joué mais j'ai ouï mais peut-être sur
des sites comme les dessins que c'était
possible
c'est changer tu prenais me fais le
calcul est donc là il voulait rentrer
dans cette position là tu vois
finalement il veut juste transposer d'un
elle prend pas je pensais qu'elle
voulait avoir les soins jouer avec les
meilleurs fou 5
alors là tant elle va faire quoi elle va
jouer alors surtout ces trois heures des
fous prendre vous hebdo du coup pour
coup j'ai trois fois déjà trois sets ça
mais c'est tellement rapide que viennent
je n'ose même pas imaginer ce que ça
peut être une partie de glisse contre
toi oui j'aurais joué 3 rien je me suis
un peu présenté hier j'ai battu ma mais
j'étais content c'est vrai est génial je
compte en inde est dé 6,6 ils feront des
six dames d2 pour la découverte bas même
encore une fois fou ce sens qu'elle est
que je n'arrive pas à comprendre tu vas
fossé 5 oui j'aurais pris en ce sens
qu'elle ramène le tour le fond marin
vers l'europe
donc pour moi oui j'aurais joué il faut
c'est 5,4 déchets on est d'accord oui
ouvrir le four espérait peut-être
surprenant son indication sur l
ambulance sur les mines
je trouve la partie assez étrange
personnellement celle là on a du mal à
il n'y a pas trop de fils conducteurs
non il ya des idées mais on
al'impression côté noir que c'est pas
c'est pas super bien construit ouais
joseph gamin je revois des six est bien
joué ce qui se passe sur fond d'assiette
dames 2 3 bah oui maintenant il ya plus
fous ou trois pour empêcher tour b 6 oui
mais en même temps les mésententes dans
le détroit déjà tout dit sur tv5 ça
marche well as fait un coup trop tard
elle a peut-être oublié alors qu est-ce
qu encore suggéré
puisque b3 four b2 s'éteint c'est trop
dangereux il ya 5 à 4 oui 1 5 à 2 à 4 c
trop rapide j'ai je me suis dit bon jeu
dans le détroit torbey six collèges et
lycées 5
la bouche est un énorme avantage pour
les pour les noirs ayala tours il ya le
tour qui arrive ya toutes les primes a
donc dominé qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
très vite il n'y a pas un qui a avalé
prend b3 ici genre au hasard et ce qui
hier matin
quel est votre taille attend les quatre
c'est bien joué de façon tu prends le
temps par la peine de risquer ici thor
b4g vettel rentre de toute façon ouais
mais c'était plus serré - calculé parce
que du coup il y avait là la prix sar
gagner la dame immédiatement donc c'est
bien joué
et là ça fait ça fait pions plus par
contre tu vois elle réfléchit peut-être
un poil trop avec les noirs elle elle se
met un petit danger
ah oui j'ai oublié de regarder le temps
10 secondes mais là c'est une position
que tout simple et hachoud es et quand
même
et quand même tu avec 8 secondes tu peux
toujours quand même gaffe et alors elle
en aurait 15 2
plus ce serait pas un luxe elle aurait
25 secondes ce serait quand même cool
squelette joue bien on regarde foufou
des cinq affaires tour effet un g5
oui mais faut cinq cantons prise à vie
si c'est elle commence à créer les
ménages
j'ai un probablement mais oui 4 pourquoi
pas mais je préférais aussi tour g1
direct 1 mais là c'est bien ce cas la
feuillie fans quand même de cacher droit
comme ça il y avait toujours cette
cachette 3 des 6 0 à 4 très bien joué je
vois comment ces salves à monter mais ça
sent pas très bon et le roi il est il un
peu étouffé x hd incroyable quelques
coups avec deux secondes à la forme du
roi prend des cadres on fouille 5
elle va peut-être tomber un oui fana
mais à la tour b 4 à ces terribles
tomber quatre matches qui arrivent
ouais attendre quatre mains un courrier
vous l'avez metting jl était urgente et
elle était là en russie lé 10 le vertige
de trop de succès à et c'est un peu ça
c'est qu'en fait elle est tellement
remontés dans la partie au lieu d'un peu
assurée de faire le futur gm que tu
disais de jouer tranquille à la montée
le roi cattrall est parti pour gagner
elle aurait peut-être dû un petit peu
temporiser non on va voir mais en même
temps encore une fois c'est c'est
difficile de donner d'explication
rationnelle
ça devient purement oui ils là où les
fans il a utilisé le pourtour des 1 dans
la partie chevaux 4 qu'avaient les deux
yayi cavaliers de et b3 donc peut-être
qu'elle va changer dans cette partie
allez il faut il faut que li fung ting
j'allais rentrer dans le match parce que
là elle a perdu deux parties serrées bon
la première c'était à la partie perdue
de partir de résultats on va dire elle
pouvait faire au mieux 1 sur 2 allée à 0
j'ai envie de te dire cette partie si tu
perds tu es à 3,0 tu commences à avoir
le moral dans les chaussettes après un
ca fait mal c'est toi te dit je commence
à avoir le moral dans
les chaussettes et je me suis dit
comment comment j'aurais pu caractériser
l'étape de pouilly fait et voix j'ai les
l'autre extrême je sais je suis souvenu
d'une fable de la fontaine le loup qui
commence à se forger une wii il est très
très bien
je me suis dur par opposition au moral
dans les chaussettes
l'a5 c'est un petit pique bien
évidemment sinon parce que les blancs et
ils veulent ça paraît de l'espace dans
cette variante là j'ai quatre faux j'ai
trois ou quatre ans il faut absolument
me né quelque part cette structure des
pions la g500 serait une grave faute
j'imagine oui évidemment déjà je pense
qu'on pourrait prendre 1 h toi parce que
le foot il est toutes les cases blanches
après mon idée c'est quand même de jouer
cavalier 5
il faut il faut garder les pions sur
carte blanche pour un peu limité
l'action du fou quoi donc qu'est ce que
c'est parce que les gc cette fois c'est
et c'est probablement les blancs ils
veulent quoi roigé deux tours h1 will et
blanc montrent souvent le roi dans cette
position là après mme faucher 3 f 4 f 5
tu veux célébrer il ne faut jamais
oublier aussi le sacrifice depuis un an
cette poussée avait que six dans une
position mais c'est pour ça que je me
pose quelle est la différence dans ses
positions quand je tourne bientôt rêve d
un c'est un coup un peu artificielle est
ce que tu aimerais bien avoir tu
aimerais tu préfère avoir des tours
comme ça et tu vois il vient de jouer
ici c'est l'art est pris donc elle veut
que la touche plus
pour fo 5 c3f 4g simple que la structure
de la française way qui est encore une
fois une idée très très intéressante
n'oublions pas que les noirs ne peuvent
plus rock et d'encrés l'époque les jets
de jeu est fait mais ça c'est le genre
de position que j'adore jouer avec les
blancs tu me donnes ça avec les noirs je
suis désespéré tu me donnes ça etc et
blanc même si c'est pas forcément mieux
je suis très heureux et ça c'est ce dont
j'ai parlé hier c'est quand blitz c'est
hyper important d'avoir des positions tu
te sens bien donc là je sais pas si oui
fans elle se sent bien avec cette
structure
mais si tu te sens à l'aise en blitz est
très agréable à jouer ça oui c'est
exactement ça a même temps bon
l'avantagé minime dans cette position là
c'est plus dur et sentiers encore une
fois il est très physique pendant les
parties
quand tu as dit je ne sais pas très à
l'aise et vraiment physiquement on se
sent étouffée moi j'ai remarqué qu'il ya
des positions pendant les parties
d'échecs et qui crée presque les crises
d'angoissé c'était vraiment incroyable
j'ai dit à la tv l'impression de tête au
fait elle est bien joué ça je pense
parce que tu as d'ailleurs ifan cheikh
tape à leur tour caméras mais elle a
elle a fait un petit un petit rictus au
moment de tours h7 parce que oui mais je
crois que le problème c'est qu'elle
voudrait avoir le temps de fou g3
échangé à l'appareil
elle voudrait changer qu'une paire de
tours est l'objet d'un échange et 2 pts
elle voudrait pouvoir faire tout h un
échange et les tours mathieu voit le
problème de fouché 3,6 et les concret
donc tu prends des quatre étapes à tapas
le temps que je suis de vous prendre
cinq tours h2 quoi tu te fais dépasser
sur la colonne h
mais alors est-ce que tu joues f4 et
c'est alors il faut protéger le fou tu
as envie de prendre tu vas tomber de
jouer aussi
quatre élèves 3 mai pour couvrir c'est
bien joué bien sage et honnêtement si
j'avais pas vu le coup mais on le voyant
c'est ce que j'aurais joué mais
attention à des quatre pouces et 6 après
évidemment encore une fois c'est une
idée très typique ma main sacrifier un
pion dire comment on allait mieux les
structures de la française fautrel et
berlinoises je ne sais pas
si jamais peut-être tu fais tour de
tours à schwyz où j'ai trois tu couvres
la deuxième avec la tour pour préparer
fou j'ai trois en fait c'est comme ça
surtout quand tu peux me rendre à schwyz
fourchette 3 4 elle a peint et qu'est ce
qui se passe sur food à 4 c'est la
question que je me pose tu sais tu sais
quoi il ya vouloir 3g 3g un tour prend
b2 tour c1 est rentré sur la colonne
semeta toujours faussés ciel alors là on
n'a rien compris non probants je pense
que c'était tout de suite tout à fait
possible et plausible d'ailleurs mais
parfois tu sais c'est aussi peut-être un
coup de poker elle se dit que leyti
n'diaye elle va doubler absolument sur
la colonnade si tu fais un coup c'est
pas si évident de encore doré considérer
cette situation comme unique et ce
métier donc je me suis dit et de changer
complètement de conception dans la
position
elle a compris qu'elle voulait garder le
faut je pense que j'ai compris en fait
pourquoi fouet f4 tu sais quoi il
voulait changer les tours sur la colonne
des rebelles à tours en c1 et jouer tu
sais y'a qu'une colonne ouverte le fief
4control la colonne c est faire un nul
je pense qu'elle a elle voulait juste
donné le pion et et la finale leur
opposer avec la tour devait être nulle
pense qu elle l a calculé ça ou iphone
et green team gym j'ai zappé un tabac
rien qui me plaisait beaucoup plus de
temporiser avec toray 2 joseph au g3
wave est finalement ça revient casio
même sauf que là le fou un f4 et la tour
en 3 on aurait eu la tour de l'oeuf ou
angers 3 c'est pas oui mais le foot est
oui admet avoir évité food et 4u bien
évidemment mais juillard in fine et ça
revient au même quoi elle a laissé
l'option fou des quatre qu'elle n'aurait
pas laissé de l'autre côté on t'aura de
est-ce que c'était possible d'être pro
-5 dorée celle qui la doublait je dirai
ce que c'était vraiment une menace
positionnelle je sais pas parce que
tourner 5,17 permet quand même lamentait
rouages et trois rois f4 tap le g5
non c'était cassé sur le team jc sûr
qu'elle s'est trompée là ça fait pas
sens en prendre pour revenir enfin en
fait les derniers coups c'est tour à
schwyz vous prend des quatre tours c8 et
elle menace pour ces deux donc c'est sûr
que ça va parce qu'à la faire bon après
ça doit pas grave hein tu fait tour à 20
tours c2t changer tour et c'est nul mais
tim jc trompé non je suis parfait tu
sais quand je regarde les parties comme
tt joué en ligue chinoise parfois être
ccg parfois j'ai du mal à comprendre les
plans et s il est possible qu'il y ait
un historique autre chose mais parfois
je me dis mais ça ressemble à une partie
de deux ordinateurs
je sais peut-être l'aider sera réglée du
coup plus tard ce qu'elle avait envisagé
je sais par quelle chance qu'elle s'est
trompée la main donc est ce conte
comment échoué elle revient de tours à
deux maintenant pour ce cadeau
d'affaires tour d2 oui mais il ya le
fait en 1 44
ça c'était une faute 1 à 4 c'était
bizarre d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas
une belle partie celle là les deux
autres partis étaient sympas celle là
est un peu ce qui se passe sur terre des
quatre encore fia cet éleveur récupérer
1,5
balleux doit faire tour des 3 vallées
prendre b3 j'imagine puisqu'elle va
faire tourner trois des quatre pouces et
si ceux ci un oui moi je peux jouer
c'est au tour des 3 et peut-être même
des quatre coups de suite
bâle a cédé 4 à mon avis est fou si je
pense que ting j va l'emporter là je
vois pas dans quel monde tu défense avec
les blancs puisque maintenant il va y
avoir le roi qui va être faible aussi un
sont pas rentrés dans le match et encore
il ya beaucoup c'est bien puisqu'ils
sont même pas les imprécisions je vois
si elles sont des fautes des gaffes pour
ses quatre tours de 4 est la limite
j'aurais donné le clan à 4 après ce sont
des joueuses qui se connaissent bien
parfois quand tu connais bien ton
adversaire c'est plus difficile de
rentrer dans le match
ce que tu veux éviter des choses où tu
sais qu'il est plus fort et c est un
genre de mind games qui est trop
présente
ah oui c'est exactement ça dont je
parlais tu vois quand je parlais de
l'historique est tout à fait possible
que ya un vécu une sorte de déjà vu en
3g 3g si probablement qu est-ce qu
est-ce qui ne voient pas l'intérêt
d'avoir provoqué à elle veut ça mais bon
il met un pion sur noir qui va se faire
attaquer mais ni 3g 6 tours 1 tour 5
peut-être si tu y arriveras mais très
bien joué et c'est pourquoi j'ai préféré
tous ces fous de 8 parce que je voulais
attaché au fcc
j'aimais bien avec les mêmes aidés je
voulais être le point d'être attention
pas cependant un moment vous réussissez
à sa marche pas le public l'ouémé fou
prend roi prend et f4 bon là pour le
moment ça ça tient mais il faudra faire
attention vessier vc cp c'est vrai tout
un corps une petite précision faut
peut-être revenir en a c'est pour aller
partout des huit tours 5 au final c'est
pas mal fait et je reviens dans pitt en
piste a pas vraiment perdu de temps au
final oui c'est une des choses plus
difficiles à faire tu saches hector et
connaître alors attiré vient maïs et en
même temps c'est simple allez des 4b
qu'intéresse attendent vous prend 1,4
mais a peut-être des problèmes à quatre
des cinq bien joué oui mais fou des 5,7
chez bhl et les pions donc tourbe et
trois peut-être réussi qu'est-ce qu'elle
s'assure qu'elle devait repasser avec le
fonds aux 5 c'est évident en fait je
veux dire par là où beaucoup d'avant bon
bah on voit ton pion de toute façon oui
autour h à la tour à charge et bien ça
c'est bien vous avec peu de temps sur la
pendue c'est difficile ça comme coup
elle veut tout racisme ou g5 à mefou g5
pour prendre ces 2 et wii quel
retournement de situation autour h 50
armes et des rentes laisse très bien
joué de la part de l a vu ça une vitesse
c'était l'aider du coup faute de west et
c'est sûr il ya la vue le piège et cour
prend des 5 tu vois avec le si peu de
temps à la pendule je trouve que c'est
très bien joué je sais pas si ça gagne
mais au moins avec les blancs tu es sûr
de pas perdre
il ya plus de pièges et et tu fais
marrer mais j'ai très bien défendu sa
aussi tout reprendre et de toi et c'est
nul
en fait être joue bien par phases
il n'y a pas de partie très construite
et très propre de a à z mais par contre
sur le petit jeu tactique elles sont pas
mal les deux déjà qu'est ce qui est
mieux classé en bullet with iphone
largement bullet et ambühl est par
contre sitting j ai dit c'est bien on a
discuté et 6 heures je te parlais
quelque part en fait de notre éducation
classique et que j'aimais je voulais
était que c'était considéré comme
néfaste pour tous les entraîneurs il y
aura juste tombés tout à fait par hasard
sur un interview sur une petite
interview de vladimir kramnik qui depuis
un certain temps on traîne déjà les
jeunes joueurs indiens
probablement que ce sont eux les
responsables mais aussi de cette
renaissance
j'essaie de les coller indienne pléthore
de ce coeur joie il a dit qu'il leur est
interdit
je voulais tout simplement ils n'ont pas
droit non mais ils le font quand même
hein je peux te dire que oui oui mais
femmes peux te dire que sur thiès comme
on les voit il le faut un niveau de
difficulté mais oui il a raison de
l'interdire il a dit qu'est ce qu'il a
dit c'est assez c'est assez rigolo parce
qu'avec 100 sérieux leur égard très
pragmatique dit et j'ai roulé ce les
chéquiers et la pendule est votée par
minute habitants l'été sam les pièces
saba
mais c'est un beau jeu aussi un le
bullet c'est ça semble pas être une
bonne chose mais après tu vois il ya un
joueur comme fil rouge as tu vois c'est
bizarre de le dire mais il a un petit
peu appris et progressé aussi grâce aux
bulles est alors pas grâce aux bulles
est uniquement mais il a quand même
passé lui passer des jours et des jours
et du jour à jouer en bullet et à force
d'en faire il a aussi appris des choses
quoi c'est bizarre pour les anciennes
générations les anciennes écoles mais
c'est peut-être qu'aujourd'hui c'est
aussi une manière de briser dire que tu
veux dire que ça fait partie
d'apprentissage à tous de le battre de
l'ère moderne quelque part mais même
temps tu veux si tu n'as pas le temps
quelque part de de réfléchir syrte tu
vois beaucoup plus d'opposition se
rappeler c'est comme si tu devais voir
un million de membres poker tu sais
pourvoir pour construire un échantillon
demain je sais pour avoir des
statistiques peu juste je ne pense pas
que ce soit vrai pour les échecs où on a
souvent le savoir fonctionne comme une
éponge dissimule pendant des années et
je serai sûr bien plus tard et peut-être
pour le nombre de partis et je suis
d'accord mais est ce que tu es le ton
forcément de saisir toute la complexité
de certaines finales technique
j'en ai pu avoir discuté avec avec deux
personnes qui fournissent des avis
différents avec avec vlad et mv l'on ne
peut parler de ça et finalement je peux
dire que le point commun dans ce que
disent les deux c'est que ça peut faire
progresser mais jusqu'à une certaine
dose en fait ça peut être pas si mal
mais faut pas trop en faire quoi que tu
vas on a commenté le coach et stores
apparaît et il y avait quelques phases
on a remarqué plus fair use as il
tolérer ça il
il avait des lacunes mais qui était
extrêmement élémentaire tu sais dans les
finales
l'acteur américain qui se sont insurgés
tuent ses 110 mais c'est pas possible
c'est pour moi le plus fort joueur de
cette tour doit tisser un blitz quelque
part et au final parfois il fait il fait
des dingueries quoi et donc je ne
pouvais pas croire donc elles passent
énormément de temps à étudier les échecs
que je pense que par exemple s'il était
affublée d'un coin tu comptes tout comme
markov c'est ça aurait changé
pratiquement tous anciennement ah bah ça
c'est sûr et je suis d'accord avec toi
et là qu'est ce qu'on avait on allait la
catalane ben laden
non mais ne vous jamais une catalane
contre lui non on avait laissé les verts
ça sert mais c'est justement ne joue
jamais une catalane contre lui enfin
c'est ça sert à rien il va te mettre le
fond j'ai deux ça va être terrible mais
non mais c'est intéressant ce truc de
bullet mais d'un autre côté ça aussi le
point positif de faire voir comme tu
disais beaucoup de tactique de tactique
différente et c'est un peu comme faire
des puzzles
pendant des heures et des heures ça te
fait progresser dans le petit jeu
tactique donc c'est ça doit être comme
tout il faut pas en faire en excès quoi
oui mais deux ans que oui c'est un trend
le cerveau à reconnaître comme ça je
suis d'accord mais mais ça donne de très
mauvaise habitude tu sais je ne sais pas
de le faire vite fait de ne pas donc pas
se poser ah non clairement la remonte la
montre et l heure c ça regarde bien pour
les blancs dans gros centre c'est une
cata là c'est pour ça que je voulais
dire que vlad et il aurait mais je ne
sais pas appelé pour cette balade ils
arrêtent la pendule en gt demande
pourquoi tu continues à jouer les
avantages matériels et est pas encore là
mais l'abattage présessionnel vie d'un
homme a déjà dans ce genre de positions
en analysant après midi jacques pas
quand je comprends pas pourquoi il me
fait perdre du temps pour aller au bar à
quoi ça ce oui mais en même temps il a
tu vois ça c'est une approche aussi de
l'époque tu arrêter l'analyse là un
moment donné on a évoqué aussi ce sujet
là parce que les ordinateurs il
ils ont complètement changé aussi le
prisme à travers lequel vous allez on
regarde les positions maintenant avant
comment s'entraîner ou en aller jusqu'à
une certaine position l'a dit maintenant
les plaintes sont très simples comment
va réagir le joueur de l'époque moderne
la loi te dire joue oui oui c'est ça oui
il va qu'on il varie vérifier encore une
fois qu'elles sont les ressources
défensive de la position il va
probablement approfondir l'analyse dit
oui alors que aller à l'époque même tu
voyais dans leur attitude les parties
les perdre et très rapidement quand et
des mauvaises positions des parties
durer cinq six coups et puis bon ben oui
bof
alors qu'aujourd'hui les mecs s'accroche
à fond aussi alors quand quand ils
jouent les positions cei oui c'est une
énorme qu'elle était je sais parce que
on craque souvent je sais quand on
n'arrive pas à gagner ses positions
gagnantes la roë commence à tourner des
jeux
un moment donné tu prends un c6 ou un
truc comme ça et comment sarine
découverte sacrifice de dames
positionnelle je sais pas mais il peut
il peut se passer plein de choses
la partie peut complètement tourné la
peur mais là c'est si ça peut être
mauvais hein mais c'était juste pour
dire que genre de choses je sais pas ce
que j'aurais tenté la limite c'est 5,5
au moins ça a le mérite d'être protégée
du risque pas de perdre le flanc tout de
suite c'est à 5,5 à contrôler youtube et
4 qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pendant ces
5 ça c'est changerait pas mal de pièces
il faut faire attention aux cavaliers
des six poules voilà des jours d'un des
trois avec cette idée là des clous et le
garde la possibilité de jouer cavalier
des six après prison c'est cinq des six
est aussi là qu'on va voir
il ya eu 5 avril et des six aussi il ya
des cinq ou six qui peut exister
oui des 5 c'est un très joli coup des
cinq des six à là en plus à 2 38 contre
30 secondes dating je n'ai pas loin en
vrai hockey tour des huit
je trouve que c'est bien joué parce que
de toute façon ici ses peines c'est
facile de trouver les coûts pour les
noirs parce que parfois ce sont les
seuls donc tour de vis très mal de tours
sur la colonne des jo il va essayer
d'effectuer la pression sur le plan des
quatre déjà et il doit absolument se
débarrasser de ce cavalier en bessin
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
est maintenant foxes pour le moment ce
n'est pas possible je suis pas sûr du
apprend b5 en fait je me demande si ça
me prend bessin que c'était pas mal de
voir cette caste ccist c'est quelle
pièce pour le moment il y en a pas mais
tu seras soirée cinq fausses aussi sa
mort soit quand tu vas prendre un an des
quatre mais tu prendras plein décatoire
c'est excitant quand allait prendre des
cats oui mais là du coup vu comment elle
joue la c4 c'est bizarre
ça donne juste un pion oui mais elle
sacrifier deux pions pour laquelle a
besoin de l'activité c'est l'exemple de
faire quelque chose en fait juste pour
dire je voyais plus un fouet f6 food et
4 persos c'est pour ça que j'ai été
surpris mais c'est peut-être pas mal
aussi un après la plus de temps à la 18
secondes
donc elle peut pas parler de temps là
par exemple j'aime beaucoup ce qu'elle a
fait et le sait pas si évident de
trouver des coûts donc elle est sacrifié
le pion aux ils essaient de stades et
les estuaires 6,5 et c'était des
positionnelle d'échanger les fous de
cases noires et tu te souviens comme
dans dans l'es6 céline la laisse d'or
dans l'iliade avec g3 hier on avait ce
fut un g2 qui qui est bloqué par le clan
des 5 alors vraiment qu'elle re bloc le
pion peut-être qu'elle va mettre latvala
d'amendé sept c'est bien il veut mettre
la d'amendés 6 en fait et comme celle
pourra tenir probablement il y en a vu
que les kings j'ai craqué jeu c'est
souvent quand il restait 10 secondes un
iphone elle a joué de façon agressive et
de choses elle a du mal à finir en fait
oui on a du mal à finir mais bon là ça
allait quand même si elle rate cette
partie ça va commencer à être inquiétant
pour elle ça peut la faire gamberger 1
le rater ça tout est chargé il faut
charger une tour s'est très bien joué
non il faut rentrer ouais ça c'est bien
joué elle va pouvoir rentrer dans ses 8
normalement ça doit passer ça et d'un
match suite à présent tu passes par le
côté ouimette de ma chute à 5 jeux pas
perdu encore
mais tourcoing c'est dommage cette dame
point cette non à dame g8 encore plus
fort ah oui là c'est fini
richert à protéger non madame g cette
dame prend 1,7 du coup voilà terminée et
elle a pas mal joué latine j elle a bien
elle a bien dominé d'ouverture assez la
petite pause un très mauvais choix
probable mondes deux variantes dans
l'ouverture de la part de ses fans
en fait comment ça s'est passé oui elle
est jouée chez toi et si la france
possédant la catalane après portant
jusqu'à jusque là c'était théorique
c'est oui ça aussi c'est sûr ça où cette
variante là quelque part c'est ce que je
voulais te dire les joueurs de catalan
considère qu' il n'y a que du résultat
possible s'est passé extrêmement passif
donc c'est pour ça que je critique un
tout petit peu je me dis c'est très
passé donc tu essaie tout simplement de
d'accroître ce petit avantage que tu
vois et hiv d'en jouer pour les noirs
non elle était pas facile à jouer
du coup davantage à augmenter petit à
petit avec les blancs avec les noirs
elle a jamais vraiment eu l'occasion de
jouer le gain ou même de mettre en
danger son adversaire et je pense
qu'elle changerait dans la prochaine
partie avec les noirs du coup est ce
qu'on veut et ce qu'on veut quelques
petites questions du tchad peut-être
pourquoi pas rationnellement évidemment
pour ardéchois et raté un chien à la
communauté quoi tient à l'aise pour le
moins probants n'y a pas tout moment ils
mettent des emotes il pose pas de pas de
questions spécialement je regarde sur le
téléphone n'a pas une info
importante pour un certain le match dans
le match
rien n'y a pas d'information je vérifie
pas ce que c'est que des fois je reçois
les informations après le match tu sais
je regarde pas pendant et je vois après
que après une heure de jeu il y avait il
y avait une info sur telle pose sur tel
à la pause à peut avoir une raison x ou
y ou koala dont il n'y a rien de il n'ya
rien d'important et comment ça s'est
passé votre événement et hier et il me
semblait que vous allez jouer compris
comme la tête je sais gérer contre les
contres les bras ba écoute ça c'est pas
super bien passé on a perdu les deux
matches on a perdu les deux matches
après l'événement les gens ont beaucoup
aimé on essayait un nouveau format comme
je t'avais 10 et 15 buts pour l'équipe
et on a eu des super retour les gens
vraiment adoré donc donc ça c'était cool
après là c'est un match d'essai donc
c'était un match amical encore faim
amicale s'est jamais amical mais c'était
pas voilà il n'y avait pas d'enjeu tu
vois d'habitude on joue pour des petits
paris avec les bras quand on joue là
hier on était vraiment sûr du test mais
oui écoute c'était sympa c'est la
première fois qu'on contester ça et
c'était assez marrant de se passer le
temps les uns contre les autres on a un
joueur qui nous a coûté le match en fait
il a pris beaucoup de temps pour
réfléchir et en plus il a perdu ses deux
parties d'accord
j'aime j'aime siège et 1,32 me poser la
question qu'est ce que ça va donner avec
une équipe féminine l'équipe max
féminine française combientième mondiale
d'après admira bien c'est intéressant de
penser que c'est parce que tu m'as dit
que tu envisagerait de faire le même
format oui oui quels étaient les
questions et quel serait le niveau de
l'équipe de france pour toi 6,6 à toutes
les meilleures joueuses qui vous
achètent toutes les merveilleuses chez
moi j'espère que démentent est vraiment
soir que sera naturalisé bientôt donc je
me dis si en fait à chaque fois on n'est
pas si mal classé tu sais au début de
compétition il nous manque vraiment mais
un petit quelque chose pour chez les
médailles et je pense que si l'équipe
max ou donc un mari se fit en pauline
démonter et moi si c'est possible voilà
je suis dit aux helvètes de moscou
l'année prochaine on avait vraiment une
réelle chance
donc c'est bien une équipe assez forte
en sata jouer quoi s'ajoutent up top 10
100 % top-5 aussi et du coup si ça
sourit top 3 est tout à fait possible
qu'on sera dans le temps et dans le top
6 est je ne suis pas sûr des classements
ce moment là comme tous les tournois ont
été arrêtés je ne peux se vit tu sais
l'évolution des lots et mais je pense
que oui on a une vraie chance je
m'oriente d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien
arrêter la compétition par inquiète
c'est sur une médaille de l'équipe de
france
vous n'avez jamais réussi à faire une
médaille depuis que tu vois notre
meilleure performance oui on en a que la
médaille individuelle et même la
dernière fois je la médaille d'argent
mais c'est tout ça c'est pas forcément
important encore on échoue vraiment tout
près du but et notre meilleur c'était la
cinquième place faut peut-être virer
l'entraîneur mathieu en danger un danger
pour elle-même prépare pendant des
heures je n'ose même pas l'imaginer ce
qui par quel état ils passent par
catherine dagois celle face pendant qu
est-ce qu est-ce que les prépas sont
bonnes elle est prêt pass est incroyable
qu'est ce qui vous surprend c'est qu'ils
arrivent à chaque fois à dîner chez une
idée là c'est grâce à lui ils
travaillent ils travaillent je ne sais
pas comment elle fait il ya toujours sur
nice et toulon mathieu il a toujours une
prépa il a toujours une idée il connaît
toujours une partie par correspondance
il ya toujours quelque chose
ah oui le porte parole c'est grâce à lui
d'ailleurs que j'ai découvert la base
des partis par correspondance et m'a dit
mais elle n'ira mais comment ça tu ne
réussis pas toutes les bases très
important la base par correspondance
parce qu'il ya toujours un mec qui a
joué ça dans un championnat par
correspondance et femmes battues l'a
toujours vu quoi c'est pas vraiment une
nouveauté ça a été jouée dans un match
entre ordinateurs en 1999
ah oui le courant je pense que c'est une
source inépuisable d'idées donc toujours
là mais vaillante tour bien elle reste
fidèle à cet ordre de coup droit que
j'allume l'ordi pour voir ce que ça
donne
oui pour voir la prépa la théorie exact
là dessus on souhaite toujours elle est
à dire d'après mes souvenirs c'était 2
et 1 j'ai l'impression que tim j ai un
peu mieux préparés dans les ouvertures
non finalement parce qu'avec les noirs
étaient proches de l'égalité à chaque
fois et avec les blancs est là ok là une
jeune âge d'or qui s'est pas super bien
passé mais la catalane c'est quand même
très bien passé après ce qui montre que
les femmes ne travaillent plus tu vois
c'est quelque part ça montre que c'est
une joueuse inactive l'a récemment elle
a participé dans le tournoi organisé en
ligne c'était la première femme
d'ailleurs qui était invité dans ce
tournant là ouais ben ils sont en double
et un oui est ce que je voulais dire
dans cette position-là souvent les noirs
aux cdd la décharge est le cobaye f3
jouer cavalier h4 halal fait à jouer
avec g5 serrar nantes voir les pions qui
poussent sur les droits dansez dansez
berlinoise même si c'est très logique
puisque ça empêche f4 au final j'ai
l'impression que je les ai jamais voit
tout le temps mais c'est souvent là les
rencontres donc j'ai cinq six escales et
des captages et 80 elle bloque vraiment
les pions elle veut ouvrir là que tu
vois la colonne h volant et je veux tu
peux pas doublé mais cette fois être un
bon levier est encore loin ouais mais ça
peut arriver et du cou et les blancs
maintenant ils ont du mal à faire f4 f5
c'est quasi impossible évidemment donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ici avec eux
j'ai bien elle peut utiliser les mêmes
et des jouets comme dans la partie
précédente 4 au 6 mai je me suis posé la
question 3,4 faut ici le crédit des
quatre à ce moment-là et des quatre oui
c'est ce qu'on a dit avant est-ce qu'on
si on commence par cavalier de quatre
corps chargés des dictatures les trucs
avec ses 5 à regarder ou avec à six et
cinq aussi ce qui me surprend ce que
pour elle rentre toujours dans cette
finale courrier fans elle aura plus
jouer
la variante avec détroit où les jouer un
peu plus en plus et c'est là peut-être à
vide elle pense peut-être qu'elle va
être plus forte que son adversaire là
dedans et à peut-être comme utiliser un
petit peu plus tôt un historique entre
les deux et pour une raison x ou y pense
que c'est une bonne idée quoi est-ce que
tu as cavaliers j'ai trois cavaliers ou
4 aussi pour toucher les cases noires
oui tu les as bien évidemment c'est une
manoeuvre très naturel commence par
révéler des quatre plus là sachant que
ces 5 n'est pas possible puisque tu
joues des cinq allemands il ya fou des
mythes encore donc il faut toujours
faire attention dans cette position là
mais à six dont quelques jeux ce sens
qu'elle peut pas jouer une fois ci ce
niveau de cette cour il a peut-être peur
si les noirs joffo de 7,17 aider la
suisse c'est un sacrifice positionnait
les fauves 4 tout simplement après je ne
sais pas si elle allait à ces think of
you et 6 d'être mieux avec les oies ou
en tout cas de complètement égaliser à
dire si ces cinq cavaliers bois 3 b 6
mais bon après le cavalier il sera mal
placée en b3 il sera mené dans les
pionts et quand tu mets situer le fou en
bessette tu vas jouer le match aussi
après un moment donné donc elle fait
aussi je pense c'est bien joué mais
c'est ce qu'on s'est dit qu'il va
probablement utilisé et si soares que
ici ce serait bien de prendre un point
avec les plans donc 6 x 4
les délais risquent en alliant
associations halte en dessous des 6 vous
prendre que l'on prend et dessins que tu
auras encore car elle y eu deux cas
relief quatre peut-être toujours de
choses oui mais tu n'as pas vraiment
envie de jouer des 5 es tu sais parce
que même avec un peu de moi tu auras est
la même structure mais oui tu vas
réussir à briquet mettant à mal choix
mais on n'aura pas le choix après
qu'avait l'aide
des chauffe eau déchets ce qu'annonce
que ça va rentrer dedans après avoir que
si on bouge le cavalier n'importe où fou
prend un f4 n'est pas possible à tour
des huit tours à schwyz donc à l'a25
n'est pas possible non plus ouais
peut-être qu'il aurait lieu 2 c'est pas
dit qu'on a tous les cas mais les deux
ans l'attend un métalleux 5 parce que
vous prend aux cinq faut prendre cinq
tours des huit le fou problème est donc
t'as pas car sinon qu'à radio deux ça
aurait été fort ainsi avec avaya 2
c'était terrible au quai vallet es5
elle a un peu de réussite latine j parce
que carey lieu de cinq
fallait vraiment l'avoir c'est pas sûr
que de loin l icône chez cavalli b33 et
fonctionner oui mais non faut prendre 5
vous prend aussi à ces enquêtes
pourraient encore tourage cinq tours eux
deux ouais bien mais je vais dire est un
mets en garde cette possibilité de
laisser saint caprais aussi c'est pas si
mal joué mais bon les noirs doivent
rentrer dedans parce que sinon t'as pas
de coup n'a pas le choix on fait et quoi
puisque fou c'est cette foule prend
fouet cette france et 7 c'est mort ces
passionnés un crochet oui je dois je
vais 5 du doigt et tu dois rentrer là
dedans tu n'as pas le choix vous prendre
ici c'est une trop grosse menace
oui oui non mais j'y réfléchissais s'il
y avait un moyen d'échanger une tour
mais même si au final il est très
désagréable donc 5 qu'il faut qu'on
regarde de 5 je pense que les noirs
venge 5 dans cette position-là fois que
tout sera échangée qui alors a doublé
sur la colonne où on verra bien tu fais
roi f7 tu laisses pendant les cinq tués
le fou en russie et en vrai ça doit
aller non oui je me suis même d'une
partie jouée par wesley so contre gris
chocolat chaud quoi sociaux ils ont
échangé pratiquement tous et tous les
pions sur les lumbrois est en fait plus
vous avez
et la suivante le roi 96.5 tu voyais
c'était si terrible et noir là il va se
développer dès cette façon là après du
bloc quoi me to blue qui le pion à 1,6
et protège des gaz de schiste donc il ya
jamais tour de suisse
donc je pense que les noirs comme ça
clairement pas sera clairement pas parce
que tu vas jamais sortir le fou oui à l
végétaux reste 5 tours des 5 mai ses 4
bonjour comment tu t'es ok mais je sais
45.61 juste j'ai l'impression que c'est
très artificielle admira c'est très
artificielle est encore une fois c'est
une ouverture quelle que soit l a bien
dit déjà en europe tout de suite donc
après il faut jouer extrêmement précises
tu sais que pourra voir développer ces
pièces et parfois même de reprendre
l'initiative ce qui arrive souvent dans
les finales quand les deux faux s'ouvre
mais si je vous dit quelque chose c'est
4 donc tu dis oh ça va pas d'autres
coups parce que sinon le fou est enfermé
donc 5 pour fou et 5 est ce que tu veux
faire d'autre airwave sept tours à
schwyz it arrive à faire ça à prêter
mieux tu pars pas le cas de tout de
suite après cinq tours en peut-être fois
ci ça et tu mettais s'y poser la
question c'est y avait une tactique un
et pas de tactique non j'avais pas vu
juste ok mais bon j'ai baissé de 1,5 c
est très bien joué elle menace que a
laissé six faux 17 ya pas qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire et si je sais parler
c'est une partie qui a été très mal
négocié l'ouverture surtout pas perdre
donc enfin c'est pas perdre ça doit être
perdants mais s'est pas perdue je veux
dire il peut encore sauver le demi point
il n'y a rien de moins qu what a pâti au
moins t'es tu mets la tour à tour des
cinq îles caraïbes et 6 avril non c'est
horrible
désolé je pensais qu'il y avait encore
tour des 5 et la sicile non là j'ai
pensé depuis se fait depuis trois coups
je pense au coût de 8 mois mais autour
de lui tous les jours moi je voulais moi
je dis face aux stratégies que j'ai bel
échange de l'info elle elle gagne tout
de suite la pièce deux pièces mineurs
pour la tour non et en plus tu vas
mettre le feu aux cinq l'option b 3 ça
bouge plus et c'est vrai tous ces lots
de piaf ou des six à leroy 17 encore non
donc ya pas j'allais dire tu peux gagner
le pion pas encore en cette fougue 5
juste fou et 5 x 5 aussi avant
l'événement obama voulait le petit piège
feu cinq tours b 4 food et six en fait
c'est très bien oui c'est une finale lot
jours amende salée elle est très facile
à gagner pour effacer la gagne est donc
clair et l'a72 temps à la série même si
tu fais je pense qu'elle veut tourache 7
mai après roy ait fait un tour à chéroy
roi ici tour à jules droiture même
cavalier 3 tu vois pour couvrir le pion
g
les fumerolles tomber oui il faut
baissier ceci avec les dégâts vont
n'empêche pour ses 5es 4es la f6 tour
j'ai six cavaliers ou cinq étrangers
quatre échecs
voilà déjà l'on a gagné 1,2 pion aux
laïcs et des six maires ça gagner
partout mais le truc c'est que non
seulement il y avait un retard matériel
mais en plus oui comme tu le disais la
structure était délabré et du coup les
pièces mineurs et vous avez des cases
quoi et tu vois c'est que riaj et je me
suis dit que leyti n'diaye à les répéter
leur tueur est en fait c'est elle qui
change
ouais et elle repart sur la nadjaf qui
s'était plutôt bien passé pour iphone en
réalité un c'est bizarre comme choix est
pareil jour
3 il faut demander à maxime ce sens là
tel indirecte elle ne faut il pas une
aide
ce qui joue aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tiens
je vais jeter un oeil à l'aide d'un ami
est ce qu'on fait là flers direct des
demoiselles
je vais te dire je vais te dire tout de
suite si maxime jousse qui jour où on
top 12
ah oui elle tombe de haut oui j'ai
oublié parce que j'attends ça qu'elle
est déjà j'ai cessé de partis ou trois
partir ou pas du tout il en a joué 2 je
crois je sais pas combien il doit jouer
sinon jouer 2 3 4 jeudi des équipes en
face je vais te dire s'il reste encore
des matches importants
je cherchais son équipe baky qui a déjà
fait nul avec les noirs à l'onu labaki
les différences par rapport à la partie
précédente ce qu'elle a pris avec la
dame en d4 et elle joue j'ai 4 et page 4
tu voyais les changes est plein elle a
peut-être pendant vu ça pendant la pause
aussi un tu sais on n'y a pas pensé mais
il ya eu une pause cp siégé cinq chez
les 17
maxime ne joue pas aujourd'hui
maxime ne joue pas aujourd'hui mathieu
joue match haché mais joue pas contre
une équipe très forte elle joue contre
une équipe supposée plus faible mais tu
vois là ici tu vois je
j'ai questionné le coin f4 tout ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et je dis que
ce avant que je sois s3g 4 au g4 tout de
suite donc là la taille des blancs et y
est plus rapide mais plus rapide ballet
icône elle va faire le g5 h 4 h 5 g 6
dont on a parlé mais oui elle veut avoir
économisé des temps et un hockey
qu'est-ce que je jouais si les fans h 5
g c'est ce qui arrive en garde est
tellement en retard ou iphone
en vrai donc c'est quand même de
transférer le cavalier ces quatre ânes
ont peut-être f4 pas classique mais qui
avait laissé chez c'est ça mais alors
demandé de jean pascal est tellement mal
après moi c'est un peu le même problème
qu'avec l'autre position comme ces trucs
que j'aime bien jouer avec les blancs
j'ai toujours l'impression que c'est à
deux coups de fer match tu vois moi j'ai
l'impression que je suis je suis a g6 de
faire échec et mat quoi alors que pas du
tout ça joue encore après tu peux même
défendre etc
mais mes jours cette impression est ce
que quelque part tu es très lâche dans
ces moments là tu dis c'est bon j'ai
gagné cette partie
oui oui je peux me dire ça oui je note
gina tocard ou un jeu un match tu sais
j'aime c'est dur quelle stratégie
adopter je suis toujours très confiant
de toute façon quand j'ai mes positions
bah là il ya aussi h six f4 un qui me
donnerait très envie pour jouer sur le
match aurillac c'est l'âge parce que
cette position est là où il est
absolument hors de question que tu fais
tu perds une pièce je pense 4e dans ses
positions là ne demande pas le mirage te
dise et ses abandons pour les noirs déjà
bassin trop vite
non mais regarde juste les pièces et
ernie els de damian oui mais là nos
carences je pense que c'est
justifiez vous justifiez rue après jc
sur quatre je vois pas comment garder la
pièce il ne pas jouer j'y suis dans
cette position là que faire jouer
quelque chose comme tour à ses 8 doit
finalement née des critiques on n'a pas
compris pourquoi le retour en bus dans
cette ouverture est maintenant on a
compris et systématiquement le seul coup
probablement dans cette position là pour
ne pas perdre votre site
qu'attends tu prends en g7 ça je pense
oui tu dois prendre je sais pas qu'est
ce qu'elle mangeait bon j'imagine
non je n'aurais jamais pris je rajoute
offset quelque chose doit se tenir un
coûte que coûte
pour le moment il faut toujours faire
gaffe aux menace d'orage 7 comme tu le
sais très bien mais tour h7 ya aussi six
cavaliers par des jets 6 puis on prend
tour à je suis tout reprend 1,8
classique tu en prends ici j'ai pas aimé
tu vas j'aurais préféré 4 garder un peu
de mais bon c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
que taxer moins précis 4 4 mais oui à
mon ami wayne rooney dans cette finale
est là qu un pion de plus après tout
ranger 701 romans elle reprend g7 bien
quelle puce mais en même temps le roi un
noir est très faible
tu vois c'est un facteur très important
dans cette position là même un final
puis la f458 manque le s4 j'aime bien
que 4 4 juin même pour éviter les fuites
il ya aussi foire 5 nous on l'a raté
complètement dans l'autre mesure où je
sais pas si c'est possible les foires 5
roger 5 tu voyais gagner peut-être une
qu'elle était au défender cette ferme on
est bien là
mais on est parqué dans ce match on est
pour le suspense
pour les poires le sait c'est qu'il
garde dans ce match programmé moins fan
est une grande favorite mais elle a très
peu de pratique ces derniers temps
whiting meeting j je la voyais moins
forte que ça en vrai je vois je pensais
que ce serait plus one aux étiquettes
quoi bah c'est pas si clair clair comme
as tu sais pas 100% ou diffèrent d'un
mois via la victoire et a vu que vous
avez commenté pratiquement tous les
matches je ne sais pas comment ils
jouent en boulettes yfm est-ce qu'elle
maîtrise
un jour elle joue mieux que ce que
j'aurais pensé à première vue mais team
gym avait impressionné a thing d'accord
maritime qui est assez forte elle a
l'air elle avait l'air assez forte après
ça dépend tellement aussi du match up
c'est cette bulle est de la forme ça
joue un peu au physique aussi des matchs
son nom oui c'est vrai je vais vous
qualifier cette dimension physique avec
katerina l'agglo engines j'ai posé tout
simplement la question joueuse mais
comment ils s'en prennent à ce que j'ai
j'ai l'exemple est mon amie alexandra
kosteniuk je sais que je tire une blague
non et elle est moche et courir tu sais
si c'est une condition sine qua non en
fait pour tenir dans les tournois
d'échecs et nana m'a dit qu'il allait
régulièrement à la gym et elle a
continué à courir mais sur son balcon
parce que maintenant il alors une
machine sur le balcon en plus regardées
thing j le truc qui est bien fourel
c'est quand elles dominent des parties
elle domina pendu le ciel prend moins de
risque de rater
oui et regagne 1 fois 5 sérère et des
arts jour je ne sais pas quand ouais ça
va arriver au prochain peut-être à bien
être qui est des deux cavaliers ou 4l
t'aurais prendra le pion
qu'est ce qui se passe car après ça
semble mal gré qui a aidé de quelques 4
ça parait dur oui c'est pas fait sienne
pendant sept jours incluant mais là tu
as le prend trop de temps faut pas se
mettre aussi mal autant
parce qu'avec une seconde à la pendule
tu remontes jamais 15 secondes c'est pas
assez suffisant j'essaie d'avoir fois je
sens qu'ici mais faut pas donner un
échec est d'abord d'oriens que roi déchu
est probablement le seul coup les
chinois ici c'est si tout simplement on
peut pas jouer au fc cesser de tels
calculs si elle peut gagner une pièce
non aussi oui mais tous réussissent à
roye c7 je me lance t il
le joaillier mais jeudi elle doit
peut-être regarder s'il ya pas un gain
forcé quelque part à la 2 minutes encore
elle a deux minutes à la pendule si
impressionnant pour cela le temps de
polyphénols mons la gestion de temps
dans cette partie-là est trop lente
qu'elle pas et maintenant tout
réussissait maintenant tout réussi ça
doit marcher c'est ça comme ça parce que
ça attaquait les deux pièces et y avait
plus rien de reprise mais bon là c'est
gagné 3 0
la tuque apprendre à jouer pour celles
qui n'ont pas attention quand même
attention et toujours qu elle sait ce
qui est bon qu'ils gardent le plan mais
fait là quelque chose
leucate h57 elle veut quoi elle veut
tours 8
louis f cette voie la haye a pas encore
c'est pourquoi l'air qu'est-ce qu'on
vois pas qu'est ce qui se passe sur
freud pièce est quelque chose qu'on peut
dire pour les noirs oui qu'on a raté
j'ai vu des justes auront huit ans oui
donc elle est obligé de commencer par
façon elle a pourtant tué le père autant
est sûre elle était trop mal autant pour
des déjà content attaque c'est difficile
mais quand tu défends un truc pareil
alors il reste combien de temps il reste
il reste six minutes france est censée
être la dernière si metting j qui a bien
serré la vis 1 depuis son début de match
un poil raté elle a réussi à prendre
l'avantagé dans les ouvertures avec les
blancs à tenir dans la berlinoise avec
les noirs elle fait plutôt tourner le
match en sa faveur sur la dernière
berline a6 est très mal passée
wemmel elle était à moi oui oui mais
elle était pas loin d'eux oui mais on
n'est toujours pas loin dans cette
position là mais cette tâche très
difficile c'est parti allait durer très
très longtemps et tout qu'elle retourne
dans la variante elecam confiante sur ce
qui m'a fait elle change pas je pense
qu'elle s'est trompée tard ça devait
aller jusque très loin donc cavalier des
quatre ça a été jouée sg mais pas le
coin 6 je ne sais pas si c'était
possible de jouer fo 17 officiers tour
de mythe que c'est quand même les dd
noir en tout cas elle va changer quelque
part avec les noirs c'est sûr sinon elle
va perdre il faut mouiller fans se
posent la question est ce qu'elle change
pas et celles qui changent en premier
quand j'ai commencé mais je me suis posé
la question s'il rentre dans les
meilleurs cavaliers de 4,6 les noirs
jouent faux décès a réussi ce geste il a
même aidé est ce que ça marche ou pas ce
que je vais aussi j'ai essayé de
calculer flf 5 va redonner le cavalier
méprendre avec la tour en décèdent meta
tour de 8 à la fin donc en fait il n'y
avait pas de façon très confortable de
de faire deux ferries d'exploiter ce
point 17 et sinon toujours calé
d'ailleurs toujours tour de mythe
si tu n'étais naturel dans cette
variante là aussi il faut aussi l'aider
quatrième boucle après 5
c'est quoi ces soit b 3 6 4 6 4
j'aime bien et sur un bessin qui a
cavalé prendre des 5
et puisque je me disais je me suis posé
la question que trois des cinq accusés
de bessengue très bien tu sais tu aurais
voulu jouer ces cinq fausses et si ce
week-end tempo voyez tellement quentin
poule c'est pas possible il faut faire
très attention et si ça se passe plutôt
bien pour rui fans là j'ai l'impression
classée elle fait ses quatre ça va être
dur mais ces gars tu as encore floues et
4 quand même il ya un peu bizarre mais
elle pourrait repartir on g6 oui mais
dans l'absolu peut être faux quatre fois
si tu peux rentrer dans cette finale
faut juste faire attention et bien dans
mon g4 tuer le problème de cet échange
là c'est que je peux peut-être y
attaquer les plongées cap deux fois mais
je veux tout de suite joué tour de 8
il faut échanger une tour et espérons
que cette finale va tenir ce qui
compliquait parce que dès que tu es
charge une tour je vais joueurs ou à
genoux rangés trois tours de 4 et comme
un paquet sur quel dommage pas quoi en
faire grand cas je pense que les joueurs
de la berlinoise se sont dit cette
phrase
combien de fois on peut tenter contre
démonter quand même aulas était comment
je me suis préparé pour le match tu sais
que j'ai passé cette partie là et donc
c'était la première fois juste j'ai
essayé de reconstruire une marianne
zurich et là je suis tombé sur cette
partie là je comprenais pas et après on
a expliqué oui non non je me suis j'ai
compris lorsque démenti à l'époque il
m'a dit qu'il intervienne truc
incroyable
c'est fou hein de deux pas de d'avoir
oublié que l'adversaire avait déjà bougé
le roi riez mais ça montre aussi
l'intensité de ces partis et l'intensité
de la concentration qui sait d'un joueur
d'échecs c'est vraiment parfois je
compare cet état de transe si je sais
pas c'est pas si évident
en fait ouais c'est ça c'est un truc qui
peut paraître bizarre pour pour les
personnes c'est quelque chose que mes
amis quand ils ceux qui sont amateurs me
demande souvent ils disent mais tu es
tellement et concentré comment tu peux
oublier un truc superficiel mais c'est
parce que nos échecs comme tu es
tellement concentrée dans la profondeur
on peut dire ça comme ça de la position
que ça peut devenir vraiment très
difficile de devoir les choses en
surface comme un petit rock ou des
choses complètement simple quoi et
quelque part je sais je me suis dit que
dans cette situation là on voit là où
l'adversaire de démonter tout simplement
rockets des rockets je pense qu'on fait
confiance c'est l'éthique de genre
d'achat confié confiance son adversaire
tu sais moi je me suis dit j'aurais pas
doté non plus je sais c'est une question
de confiance s'est passé dans celle ci
on a oublié de dire que finalement
c'était pas parce que tu voi et angie
l'essai de d'échangés et de clouer le
khalife au chaos parce que sur ces
quatre fois ci c'est pour le moment qui
avait réussi c'est pas possible
maintenant on est en maths d'ailleurs
fin mai alors allez m'aider alors
sylvain j'ai fouillé ses points
peut-être qu'elle doit jouer six
elle-même maintenant tu sais que les
fans comme dans toutes les parties elle
a toujours tenté c'est ce que c'est
possible mais aussi ses défauts
réussissent quand même nom n'avait pas
évidemment mais je me suis dit tu vas
fils 5 aurait quand même proche de faire
quelque chose de méchant là elle veut
quoi je sais pas ce qu'elle menace mais
tu as l'impression qu'il ya des menaces
là je suis demandé s'il serait bien vite
les parce que pour le moment on a encore
le temps je voulais jouer six as tu
crois je voulais prendre à ses 7 donc
j'attaque la tôt et après j'ai
l'intermédiaire fouet cinq attaques
l'autre tour
la marché où il y avait tout rage 5 qui
siégeaient perdez ou la non je perdais
non autour des 5 c'était pas possible
parce que je sais 4 donne le tempo gérer
mes tours 17
mardi c'est quand j'étais toi je cinq
ans même après comme on dit ça j'ai pas
vu pour le matin c'était pas possible
oui dans ce petit bijou à l'échafaud et
5 protéger le cavalier attaqué la
tournée c'était pas facile donc cavalier
f5 pour menacer c4 est l'otage bébé 5 et
6 4
quand même impasse que sur pions prend
pions prend vous prend et d'avoir
cavaliers g7 fou j'ai cinq et on prend
des huit qu'elle a raté je suis certain
c'est plutôt si tu prends tout tu peux
prendre en 2004 tu gagnes une pièce un
enfant de 3 à 6 et la canonnade est
complètement folle pour fonder 3-4
fouilles 5 pouces et 8 gagne pas là pour
elle c'est au tour de karine d'un quart
d'heure et moi j'ai quelques lecteurs
des cups 25 fausses évidences mais tord
de catch gagné une pièce comme donc
c'est bon ça ça marche aussi jambes donc
ça marche partout on sait qu'apple fr
s'attend font des huit tours 4 elle
s'était déjà joué à mais elle peut le
faire avec vous au 6 et par foot est roi
willem idées à la minute des roulettes à
la même idée que tu as lu mais oui food
est roi la reine a raté l arrêté à la
rate et récemment à quel point tu vois
c'est les coups d'attaqué ses frontons
des cas c'est facile quand même un
normalement elle valoir
maintenant on en attend on défend je
veux dire c'est puis ira voir tour des
cas tu peux le raté mais en attaque
tandis qu'as tu le vois que c'était pas
vraiment à côté de la flex ces gens dont
tu étais pas dans la tête
c est donc cette séquence de cinq ans ce
sera la dernière partie oui mais c'est
dommage qu'ils allaient qu'elle ait raté
faut aussi ce parce que c'est un risque
avec les mêmes dérives c'est facile d'en
comprendre alors on en est où
donc c'est la fin de la cadence et ça
fait quatre et demi à
à deux et demi pour beaucoup ok sachant
que quand j'ai discuté avec will find
dernière fois c'était pour rendre les
âges et sa participation en coupe
d'europe
il m'a dit que si les parties commencé
vers 14 15 heures leur heure locale
locales et européennes bruit que c'était
relativement de tard pour elle donc je
sais pour ça que les matchs commencent
déjà à 1h30
oui oui quand on dit que c'est une
joueuse chinoise en fait 10 km ou 6 juin
ce qui participe il commence à 13h30
il m'a dit que oui elle doit être très
très tôt à la nuit leur société donc je
ne sais pas si l'année scolaire l'année
académique universitaire s'est terminée
en chine
keller 9h 10h en chine
il disait la vue du match nice vers
minuit je crois c'est terrain pour jouer
après oui mais surtout les boulettes
c'est ça tu m'as dit que leyti n'diaye
elle joue très bien ouais ouais c'est
une très très bonne joueuse en bus
lettre ait donc ce ne sera pas évident
ça va correspondre quelque part auquel
on avis 3 4 points d'écart pour être
fins relatif un tranquille non mais mais
pour pour être vraiment favorite qu'on
va dire ça comme ça
il lui faut il faut 3 4 points 3 4
points d'écart quoi parce que y'aura y
aura 8 9 bullet et si elle est moins
forte elle peut perdre et peut perdre 5
3 6 2 quoi c'est possible et elle reste
que les jeunes regardent les cv retire
parce qu'on a vu dans le match précédent
il ya donc on a vu que les joueuses ont
complètement changé
les ouvertures sur touré rica elle a
commencé à jouer l'aller qui n'ont pas
ce que les choses vont un peu modifiée
lors leur approche pour le propre camp
on va voir un nom fait hier en tout cas
oui c'est ce que je n'ai donc c'est
intéressant de voir mes fans jouent un
peu comme maxime celles restées fidèles
à ces ouvertures une question
intéressante du tchad je troue
est ce que tu sais pourquoi dingli règne
unis à bucarest n'y a ni à paris c'est à
cause des visas de sortie où il ya une
autre
oui je pense que c'est
il s'agit de quelque part de la même
motorisation que les joueurs chinois est
donc bien des prestations de sortie de
la part de l'enseignement de leurs
gouvernements mais aussi local dans
chaque région région à mon avis les les
formalités administratives sont
différentes
une double autorisation l'autorisation
il s'était pour boukari step était que
ça mettait trop longtemps à l'obtenir en
fait parfois oui on est soumis à des
contraintes pas dire qu'ils sont un peu
plus sérieux si tu peux me permettre le
mot que nous ils font beaucoup plus
attention et ce qui est dommage c'est
parce que bien mais le voit mais en même
temps ça permet aussi au g10 est
important sur le principe de grandes
choses sur ce qu'ils accordent toujours
des deux wild cards et c'est important
aussi de donner cette chance aux joueurs
locaux donc l'absence de dingli rennes a
permis de nous faire jouer
bogdan daniel diack wikia bien jouer en
dehors
y a super bien joué dans ce tournoi là
il qu'elle n'aurait pas eu cette chance
c'est une chance c'est une occasion
unique de se mesurer que cav comment je
les comprend une petite en deux sets de
ce jeu d'échec il a pas démérité
elle a très très bien joué il se
contentait pas de faire match nul 1 1
on voyait des parties il a même refusé
les répétitions contrat chaque real
mamediarov j'étais très impressionnant
il a raison il a joué son va tout à fond
mais c'est vrai que tu as peu de joueurs
qu'ils le font mais après c'est
l'absence de rapports comme ils disent
en le chat nommé mais bon ça le truc
c'est que ça ressemblait une autre image
c'est possible et ce qu est-ce que c'est
rapide je sais plus j'ai pensé que
c'était en place indemnisent gêne mais
c'est possible chez quoi oui mais c'est
sûrement rapporte qui a remplacé dingli
rennes et lille a pu jouer ça refait
remplacement mais s'il est la chaîne des
événements mais de base si avec ding
lire n y aurait pas eu rapporte donc ça
aurait a clos le débat
alors est-ce qu'elles ont pris un peu de
sucre elle mange des cerises thing j ai
commencé le voit à 1 parce que jouer à
la caméra de sécurité
c'est pour ça les administrateurs les
ans donc je vois que ça mange des ce
rythme je me souviens je mangeais
beaucoup de chocolat pendant les parties
d'échecs je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais complètement accro et je me dis
fille un peu mon alimentation parce que
on allait partir très très longues se
faisait chez au niveau du sio qui
n'étaient pas forcément très stable
j'avais des sautes les séries c'est pas
mal là le chocolat c'est vrai que c'est
addictif
c'est bon il reste combien de temps il
reste alors il ya quarante-cinq minutes
de 3.5 et 25 minutes deux ans plus un
danger c'est de décrypter le score va
tech fukushima
me c'est catastrophique at avant la
coupe du monde
faudrait que je fasse quelque chose ce
cas plus je ne sais pas si on va jouer
avec les masques normalement tous les
joueurs pour passer les tests pcr mais
avec comme quand tu ajoutes instruments
masque ou pas non mais j'ai prévenu
l'arbitré de toute façon on a fait le
test est certes tu sais je ne vois
absolument rien avec la buée ya plus
ce qui est plus dur dans mon cas ce que
je me suis cassé le nez trois fois donc
du coup en fait si la moindre pression
je resterai travail et dont tu as fait
pour tout casser le nez autant dire que
je suis tombé quand j'étais enfant trois
fois si on m'avait dit tu te battais
avec les joueuses a pris les parties et
à jamais testé l'opération pour les yeux
non pas encore mais parce que fais tu
sais ça allait jusqu'à en ce que l'année
dernière ma femme elle a fait y'a pas
longtemps elle met plus de lunettes
depuis plus rien elle est très heureuse
et pratique
c'est très pratique en fait est ce qu'on
m'a dit ce que soit j'ai mes deux paires
de lunettes différente parce
qu'apparemment en fait j'ai genro a ni
de près ni de loin ça donc il faut faire
quelque chose je vois les chéquiers
comme c'est très bien mais il faut que
tu fasses attention parce que ça peut en
plus quand tu joues ça peut donner des
migraines émigra quand tu vois mal ça
peut être ça peut vraiment fatigué tu
peux ne pas 20 pas t'en rendre compte
tu t'en rends compte que tu peux te dire
que tu compenses est en réalité c'est
terrible pour le pour le cerveau oui
mais c'est déjà le cas donc je me suis
rendu compte pendant les compétitions
surtout par équipes
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de pression
alors qu'elle était une once d'or fut
une nouvelle fois et c'était de nouveau
une chèvre d'un gars de nouveau le
cavalier parti et ça calcule côté thing
est là mais tant qu'elle est là et il a
dit c'est que là elle a mille fois un
chef de sa garde à vue concentré comme
jamais dit mais vainqueur de gangsters
comme
oui tu te fais un petit air de gangsters
oui de gangsters high speed dans ce sens
là tu vas espiègle ouais ouais une
certaine impertinence tu vois je
compterai les meilleurs joueurs je vais
pas me laisser faire
non non c'est sûr qu'elle veut pas cessé
de faire ça se voit non non elle a pas
l'air d'être impressionné à la caméra ça
a pas l'air de l'inquiéter plus que ça
c'est mais c'est vraiment bizarre qu'on
ne voit pas plus vous en europe c'est
vraiment étonnant parce qu'elle est
vraiment forte en réalité c'est quoi son
et lougheed tiens j'allais regarder
match 7
les réponses de ding lyrique et main qui
m'a surprise d'ailleurs parce que je lui
ai dit après c'était la première fois
d'ailleurs que les joueurs chinois
gagner dans un tournoi aussi prestigieux
tels que c'est le cas ouais vous à part
des il m'a dit mais enfin ayez donc je
me suis posé la question sur sur le
retentissement dans les médias la
couverture de comment on allait le
laisser sa victoire il a dit qu'en fait
que c'est un tournoi privé
quelque part les médias officiels ne le
suivent pas forcément ils sont
intéressés que pour la coupe du monde
les tournois par équipes donc tous les
tournois officiels ce qui est ce qui
concerne circuit privé tu vois c'est un
tournoi c'est tout en fait c'est marrant
tu sais pas ce que en réalité ça pas de
vrai mais en quelque sorte chez nous
c'est un peu pareil quand même dans le
sens où vraiment quand tu as les
tournois privés mis à part les médias
échiquéen sinon les grands médias ils en
parlent vraiment jamais alors que si
maxime avait gagné les candidats par
exemple si on avait gagné les olympiades
ou même s'ils gagnent la coupe du monde
en fait ça va ça on va en parler mais
j'en discutais ya pas longtemps avec une
avec une amie qui travaille à la fifa et
qui dit qu'en fait c'était exactement la
même chose pour le foot en fait c'est
déjà une compétition qui n'est pas
officiel ça sert à rien en fait
enfin dans le sens où du coup dans le
foot ce serait pareil tu aurais un grand
chef tour entre guillemets c'est un peu
l'équivalent des compétitions amicales
que font les clubs l'été
il est même pas retransmis à la télé en
fait oui mais bien mais dans
l'indifférence tu sais du jeu d'échecs
et encore une fois on en parle mais
aussi par rapport au tennis on n'a pas
de surplus professionnelle ni même le
modèle profite c'est à dire lesquels en
ce temps pour le moment tellement de
disparités ouais mais c'est pour ça à
mon avis j'en avais parlé des défis dès
janvier-février c'est pour ça à mon avis
que le public tu sais qui est venu après
queen's gambeat oui il est reparti en
fait parce qu'on n'a pas de compétition
en réalité on n'a quasiment aucune
compétition
je veux dire par là qu'ils que les gens
ils pourraient comprendre tu vois dans
quel sens je veux dire c'est moi y avait
les dents évidemment une compétition qui
pourrait transcender le monde des échecs
dans le sens qu'il y a un un jeu qui est
beaucoup plus grand que tu vois que
quand je citerai les partis et les prix
et je partage souvent quand je vais dans
le congé dans le chatt us et balla les
gens ils viennent même plus voir les
tournants en fait si on du bike and they
ils sont venus ils sont venus voir
balkaniser ils sont venus voir les
candidats et à partir du dernier grande
chaise tour à partir du grunge et sur
bucarest les gens sont vraiment partie
de manière très significative parce que
en fait ben quand il demande le tournoi
il sert à quoi
mais sur du bas tu gagnes le grand jeff
tour bucarest c'est un événement est dit
wim ça sert à quoi en fait tu sais pas
quoi leur répondre
rien en fait et c'est pour ça que je
peux comprendre si les échecs sont un
peu médiatisé en chine
je peux comprendre ce que veut dire
dingli rennes ou au final c'est normal
quelque part qu'en dehors des tournois
par équipes et des candidats que les
médias s'y intéressent pas quoi et la
coupe c'était plus par rapport à
l'exploiter celle a battu le chanteur du
monde et c'est surtout ça et au fait ce
n'était pas considéré forcément comme un
exploit par par les médias chinois pour
qu'ils attendaient plus par exemple les
médailles d'or aux olympiades de
l'équipe chinoise
la coupe du monde donc fini deuxième
c'est ça donc la dernière coupe du monde
d'accord
oui mais c'est sûr que c'est une vraie
source d'inspiration je le comprends
très bien
tu vois pas ce que
et on sait dans ses fils et sa fille est
là ces moments là donc je le comprends
très bien
oui non mais ça c'est pas cool pour pour
moi mais c'est lent parce que j'avais
cette discussion plus au téléphone
aujourd'hui mais pour moi les échecs
qu'ils ont tellement ils ont raté un
virage tellement important en fait on a
raté une chance exceptionnelle de dirt
médiatiser notre sport etc c'est
incroyable d'être passé à côté
pour moi c'est bon parce qu'ils ont
essayé de suivre plus le modèle
commercial et ja il ya un vrai paradoxe
parce que maintenant on veut que notre
sport se professionnalise j'en dirai au
revoir les droits de diffusion des
commentaires mais en même temps le
modèle commercial qu'on essaie
d'appliquer au jeu d'échecs mais je
pense qu'il ne voit pas ouais mais bon
on en a on applique un domaine un truc
commerciales qui existent f1 keane qui
n'existe plus dans le monde en fait
c'est à dire que le foot fait tout pour
parce qu'il est comme désuet parfaite le
foot ne le foot ne fait surtout pas ça
parce qu'ils savent que s'ils font comme
les échecs bas c'est le flop assuré en
fait est juste ils vont tuer leur sport
donc nous en fait on va dire moi je vois
ça comme ça on fait un truc qui fasse ai
dit moi j'appelle ça du suicide en fait
c'est ça peut pas marcher en fait ces
personnes ne va regarder ça comme ça
c'est pas possible en fait et c'est le
plateau c'est rien inventé je sais ça et
oui je me suis dit pendant qu'on
discutait élèves ça se passait mal
aurait pour nom je regarde mais en fait
je pense que leyti n'diaye avait un
certain avantage
et après la très très mal négocié du mal
à discuter et puis on regardait tous les
deux je peux envoyer le truand
s'écrouler mais j'ai dit oui la mal
négocier ce passage je ne vais pas m'en
passer
mais bon on va toujours la même
ouverture c'est toujours maintenant dit
il
elle change de plan il veut tu joues
avec cavaliers h4 j'aime pourtant en
commun et d'échangés ce qu'avaient les
lads jockeys vallée h4h que tu sais quoi
l'aider parce que tu peux pas jouer g4
encore avec les blancs et efficace
l'idée est assez simple dans lequel elle
joue et d'orages 5 immédiatement attaqué
le pion au no 5
hélas pour les fans il doit prendre une
décision
je sais comment le défendrai ce qu'elle
veut jouer 4 et là je me suis posé la
question est ce que j'ai 5 c'est
possible si probablement demain non pas
une tête de nom ouais parce que oui je
dois dire pourquoi mais il ya un truc
qui paraît bizarre à un baiia peut-être
gestion prend vous prend vous prend et
tour des huit noms ça j'ai vu oui mais
jouer après je voulais jouer franck 5
mais c'est vers 13h10 ciel ok là par
contre c'est possible les gadjé 5-5-4
man of wealth of wales 5
qu'est ce que tu penses d'après ses
positions c'est tellement bizarre ça
peut aussi être bicis tu vois pour ses 5
fu oui mais lesquelles 3 c'est beaucoup
moins bien qu'un jour et 6 et 5 6 me
regarde tourage cinqs pour moi j'ai cinq
s'était justifié quand tu joues f4 donc
du coup cette séquence de courage 5 g 5
en 5 j sais pas si ça va je n'ai pas
trop hésité pour faire tourner 8,8
vingt cinq peut-être c'est bien joué
avant oui ces cas c'est un très bon plan
parce que souvent aussi tu sais pourquoi
on joue à ça ça peut ça peut contenir
certaines ventes à jeun fait mal parce
que tu as déjà joué à cinq et quand tu
récupères tous les plans les adoptions
il ya beaucoup plus près lâchement
suffire à 4 ainsi généralement quand tu
fais à s'inquiéter non classés 4èmes
edouard regard des cavaliers des quatre
mais ce n'était pas si grave si elle
prend ici nous et si jamais tu es
toujours torts autour de 8 sur tourbe s
est donc avalé t4 qu'elles étaient 84 ça
me déprimerait tellement de jouer tous
joué tout un match que des berlinoise
avec les noirs qu'est-ce que tu joues
comme un martyr j'avais quand dame
prépare
scandinave alaska gates a dit la
scandinavie la can certaines versions
c'est ça ça se passe vraiment mal après
je peux un peut tout jouer si ça se
passe mal vu que je connais rien je peux
un peut tout jouer parce que du coup
c'est mal partout donc celle avantage
quand tu connais pas bien et que tu es
tout le temps mal dans l'ouverture
tu as besoin de beaucoup moins à prendre
oui tu as l'habitude d'avoir des
poubelles du coup ça ira
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire chier avec
leur nom moi j'aime bien de cavalli 6 3
qui a valu aux cadres depuis tout à
l'heure mais oui mais j'étais sûr que tu
allais l'émotionnel mais je me dis j'ai
toujours cru que 5 lignes un c3 est très
mal placé bien m'attends à que dire de
notre tour en 1 h 5
ouais mais bon les blonds ils n'ont pas
vraiment de manière d'avancer pour le
moment donc ça doit aller
latourelle pu revenir en âge 6 il car
oui le il avait selon h67 tour oui mais
pourquoi parce que commencent les
mouvements latéraux que sais-tu paris 7
5 tours b 6e sermonnant 1 et empêche les
rues 6 7 et 8 protège aussi les
saucisses donc 1
c'est un coup on en est c'est
fonctionnel oui toi jsb 4 et 6 qui est
ce qui est bien c'est que tu vois il
faut que le taux opérées avec la nation
stratégie resserré ses amis l'a oublié
maintenant j'essaie oui il a oublié
qu'elle avait chauve-souris 4 repubblica
toi je suit là c'était terrible nanard
vandal a oublié lui maintenant voilà il
ya un coup de fatigue un oui elle a
donné les deux pions en tête un avantage
décisif
[Musique]
attention à la ça peut être ça peut être
le tournant il reste 32 minutes dans
cette cadence si elle arrive avec quatre
points d'écart en bulles est à mon avis
et c'est terminé un coaching si elle
sert le jeu là faut pas passer à - 5 - 6
après je pense qu il
en plus aucune chance sur des richard
kingi bientôt aux championnats du monde
ça c'est médiatico et moi j'aimerais
bien tu vois qu'il ya un match de
champions du monde tous les ans par
exemple
oui mais ça veut dire un probablement à
la suite d'un circuit non qui détermine
probablement le meilleur joueur selon de
la performance encore une fois je ne
sais pas quel est ce qu elle sur l quel
sera le format idéal de cette
qualification
est-ce qu'on passe par les tournois il
faudrait il faudrait clairement
s'asseoir autour d'une table réfléchir
voir les options mais c'est en fait
c'est bizarre tu as en fait aux échecs
tuatara 15 qu'un événement vraiment
médiatique
en réalité c'est le match championnat du
monde qui est bien au dessus et c'est
très bizarre de le faire une fois tous
les deux ans parce que on ne répond
souvent quand on dit ça la coupe du
monde de foot c'est une fois tous les
quatre ans mais la coupe du monde de
foot c'est pas le l'événement important
du football c'est de la ligue des
champions en réalité sas a lieu tous les
ans mais en même temps la coupe du monde
tu vois c'est c'est un événement qui
transcende le jeu aujourd'hui plus du
foot et s'agit vraiment des passionnés
tout autour du monde doté si c'est
tellement horreur que je regarde les
matches mais non mais je me souviens
encore de comment j'ai tremblé pendant
le match france argentine tu sais j'ai
je peux pas reproduire la stratégie du
mage qui voit là j'ai lu tous les
articles dans l'équipe et il hommage
s'est muée même tu vois tout pendant
tout le tournoi c'est souvent je parle
le temps mais si c'est quelque chose qui
gère la beauté de jeu est bien plus
importante encore une fois tu es un vrai
enjeu c'est la confusion c'est sûr mais
ils peuvent se permettre de la voir
aussi rarement parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'autres compétitions très médiatique
autour et en fait voilà parce qu'elle
les circuits et s'est professionnalisé
depuis très longtemps région qui peuvent
se permettre nous en fait ce serait un
peu comme sur vélo on faisait le tour de
france une fois tous les deux ans tu as
ce sera un peu bizarre oui pis le vélo
ils se permettent pas de
ou même le tennis roland garros c'est
tous les ans les sports individuels
souvent c'est quand même c'est quand
même annuel quand c'est possible c'est
annuel quoi oui ce que je voulais dire
déjà qu'il ya une réelle différence
entre les sports individuels et par
équipes et en même temps joue il faut
vraiment réformer je suis d'accord avec
toi ça c'est des petites choses comme un
match tous les ans et des petites choses
qui sont peut-être toit pour commencer
c'est des petites réformes pas très
compliqué mais qui aiderait déjà
beaucoup moins ça te ferait un buzz tous
les ans autour de quelque chose qui dure
trois semaines serait bien pour les
échecs
la vraie question se pose pas tant sur
sur les matches mais sur comment
organiser vraiment les critères quels
seront les critères de sélection donc
réorganiser tous les modèles tu vois moi
je vais moi je verrais bien
j'enlèverai impersonnel le privilège du
champion du monde et je donnerai une
place d'office au numéro un mondial vu
que dans
en 99 90 % des années le champion du
monde et numéro un mondial allait
lougheed donc tu pourrais avoir une
place d'office à aller lougheed et la
deuxième place sur le circuit quoi oui
de l'autre côté c'est tu joues dans les
tournois d'élite
encore une fois où les autres n'ont pas
d'accès 7 permet de garder les lots de
façon artificielle tu sais voilà il faut
réformer on a eu 10 sur les critères de
sélection de sept tournois là à oui oui
mais c'est clair qu'il faut faire les
deux en même temps mais ça ce serait
vraiment pas tu as si on faisait ça je
pense qu'on aurait tous gagné 1
je pense qu'on aurait tous gagné les
gens ici retrouverez ça donnerait
vraiment de l'intérêt au tournoi tout au
long de l'année et et on verrait plus le
champion du monde enfin le championnat
des joueurs carlos rennes serait obligé
de jouer un minimum de partie par an il
faudrait pendant ces parties là qu'ils
perdent pas de vélo etc
ça donnerait vraiment dû renoncer jeudi
après avoir te dis je pense que magna ce
corps si c'est quand même un champion du
monde exceptionnelle pour ce qu'il joue
absolument tout passée cette époque tu
sais des champions du monde qui se cache
un peu bien sûr mais qui ont joué
peut-être 50 portier dans l'année qui
l'émaillent où les matches aussi dure et
tu te souviens des mois que j'ai ce
paquet qui dirait plusieurs mois voir
c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils devaient - un
jouet un je pense dans le sens où les
matches étaient tellement non oui mais
non mais magnus et sur qui sait sur qui
joue beaucoup et c'est un bon
ambassadeur ambassadeurs du jeu mais
mais bon du coup les tournois après cci
lire il un peu cette même problématique
de toute façon pour lui ce qui est
important c'est le match pour garder son
titre toi y'a pas entre guillemets le
vrai enjeu pour magnus il est qu'une
fois tous les deux ans même si lui dans
son ego il veut gagner et il veut pas
perdre deux parties mais je vois tu veux
quand tu vois donc elles sont je veux le
dire quoi pour oui il s'agit les
comprends mais même temps elle regarde
kevin là une question qui m'a posé
d'asnières
gauche pendant les commentaires parce
que on a essayé aussi de réfléchir à ce
problème là il m'a dit mais par exemple
si magnus gagne tous les tournois qu'il
a joués dans l'année tu vois mais s'il
perd le match au fait qu'il est
championne du monde qui est le meilleur
joueur du monde et en fait ça il a tout
à fait raison
parce que ça dépend si on sacralise le
titre ou s'ils ont un réforme là tu vois
ça ça dépend vraiment du de la manière
dont tu fais des réformes et la dent
pendant le quart actuelle dans le cadre
d'accueil actuelle d'aujourd'hui en fait
c'est vaut clairement celui qui a gagné
le match mais tu vois il a passé par une
qualification tu vois c'est quand je
passe par les qualifs qui sont en classe
aujourd'hui clairement c'est le titre de
champion du monde qui est qui sacrait
ouais bien sûr et quelque part ça je
trouve que c'est bien parce que
finalement les échecs ce c'est un combat
et c'est à la fin chez moi j'aime bien
l'idée que ça la fin ce sera un combat
entre deux hommes quoi tu vois ce truc
que tu t'es qualifiées tel appui à la
fin on veut voir si tu es bon match
aussi parce que c'est c'est d'autres
qualités d'être fort en match quoi c'est
encore autre chose sachez d'accord avec
toi et c'est ça aussi c'est une
confrontation épique je sais c est comme
dans une vraie drame
c'est très important je le comprends
c'est ça porte ses dimensions aussi
historiés que l'événement et en
attendant il ya quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans la partie je me suis dit là
j'ai commencé à compiler pièces et leyti
n'diaye il a une piste de plus il me
semblait copine fans après ma joie dans
ce cas était bien un moment donné
elle a sacrifié la pièce pour l'activité
est elle à elle a manqué un peu de tonus
quoi mais attends c'est pas fini parce
qu'ils ont encore un pion a quand même
qui avance oui mais très bien sur mais
bon 15 secondes encore le fond quand la
farcir un courageux et ce après tu vois
je veux d'abord bloqué le pion à et
tourache si elle veut empêcher d'autres
de sept mètres la tour en b2 faut quand
même un peu de sang froid tu vois
attention mais n'y avait pas laissé 4 3
à mon avis avait plein de choses mais
c'est tellement dur à jouer à mon avis
avait beaucoup de choses avec de roye b
4 attend c'est pas simple a gagné du
tout mais le truc c'est que y'a quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est plus forte
quand il ya peu de temps tidjy tu vois
pas où elle se met vraiment mal
authentique j'y ai joué un peu plus vite
systématiquement elle met en page 5
tours à 5 4 1 à l'aller ça revient ça
revient 4 à trois points
saleh gt1 finir par les jouets c'est ap
détroit tu vois je t'avais dit il va
finir par jouer des trois un jour j'en
avais marre non surtout je crois la
mi-mars oui des cinq sets in a commencé
à porter des coups très concret et on a
du mal parfois comprendre les coups
comme à cinq traitements très moderne
ouais mais ils ont analysé tous à ces
choses qui sont analysés avec laure ni
ce matin tu on discute haifa d'un truc
et il me disait tu imagines à l'époque
des
avant les ordinateurs genre tu aurais
joué ça avec les blancs on aurait dit
était complètement fou quoi oui oui et
je sais oui je me suis posé la même
question c'est incroyable ça c'est bien
pour les blancs enfin bien ça jouer
c'est tu prétends al'avantage mais il y
a
y'a encore de ça une dizaine d'années
t'aurais jouer ça on aurait dit bon bah
arrête les échecs
oui mais en même temps il faut aussi
quelque part prendre en compte les
particularités personnelles tirées d'un
joueur donc parfois on n'a pas du tout
échanger les dames et tout de suite
donc ce serait peut-être une fois je
sais si tu donnes cette position à
willie anderson a le grand maître
mythique c'est pas bien avec les noirs
6008 harcèle et au recel pour échanger
ces dames
ah bah oui mais il joue et ça d'ailleurs
j'ai vu des parties où il harcèle ses
genres il utilise 5 août doivent juste
pour les échanges et après ils me
regardent cette ouverture la has signed
donc vous gestion cache ses 6 3 6 4 dans
le set et surtout de cavalli bruit
incroyable
près de neuf cents cavaliers en 17 c'est
un plan qui est officiel et il peut être
pas forcément qui ne donne pas un
avantage ou noir ou autre mais rien que
d'y penser
2 à 5 je voulais le dire déjà parce que
dans beaucoup d'italiennes parce que
maintenant ça a pris les allures d'une
italienne
les blancs jouent b 4 à 4 donc ça
quelque part ça s'empêche le plan celui
de ça contre le plan et après il replace
son cavalier parce que c'est cécile est
très mal placé que les mérites calé dès
cette es1
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas fois ci soit
il joue faux à 6,7 un très bon coup je
suis complètement perdue avec les deux
couleurs je nagerai tellement et
pourquoi est ce que tu te poses la
question je saurais pas quoi faire ni
avec les blancs ni avec les noirs en
fait souvent alexandra elle me bat dans
ce genre de position augustyniak est
chaud arrive explique sandra danser si
j'ai cette position-là contre alexandra
c'est même pas la peine d'en ménager
dans ce décret est ce qu'on peut pour
que je comprenne quelque chose est-ce
qu'on peut sacrifier
et avec jean majeau rep et samba y
pêcher avec le fou est ce que je veux
attaquer à vii à des sources là oui
parce que le secret fut si typique dans
cette variante se serait révélée juste 5
h c'est fou j'ai 5
oui mais rien l'a6 trop solide mais
peut-être fruits ronds et cavaliers
prend à vous prendre tu vois moi comme
je connais toutes les aider avec triage
à cinq je ne suis pas posé la question
on va peut-être froget 5 c'est possible
comment s'est posé la question non pas
parce que ça marche ou pas mais c'est
pour rendre pour en invoquant finir avec
cette structure où je comprends rien et
enfin faire tourner trois tons g3 moins
je sais pas s'il ya ou pas vous moi je
sais ce que je fais c'est pour ça que
j'aimais pas le couffo c4 je voulais les
mentionné avant j'étais en train
d'envisager d'amis si c'est pour se
déclarer je sais pas si c'était possible
tiens d'ailleurs si on peut leur montrer
c'est une manoeuvre typique je sais pas
tu vas si c'est ici c'était possible
d'un jouet damas avait l'air correct
mais bon on ne perdez pas forcément
n'agissait pas juste ça existe
fauché quatre oui n'ont hélas pas pris
un g5 qu'elle a joué que le h5 ça part
et ça me paraît dangereux l'envi ses
souffrances et 4 ça me donne tellement
envie d'aller sacrifier des trucs fous
et 70 sites
malheureusement non mais un jour un jour
la dame qui arrive en j 6 j'en sais rien
ça me choque gens là j'aurais même pensé
prendre de f
oui mais c'est chloé n'as rien tu peux
pas mais oui j'ai alors été une très
bonne été survendue préparé je veux dire
que c'est une idée stratégique très
importante
j'aurais du mal à du coup je voudrais
tout retour des trois tours f
enfin je serai je serai matrix et par le
pion à vii toile f1 baril va faire
tourner bien sérieux la rue des voiliers
mais là je sais pas là en l'occurrence
je pense que ça tendrait les blancs
quand même
bon mais tu vas encore une fois tout ce
sera après les échanges
elle ne peut pas être changé et à juste
titre d'ailleurs parce qu'ici je pense
qu'il faut garder un tour mais je vais
peut-être que j'ai tort parce que j'ai
toujours tendance de garder une tour et
pouvoir jouer avec le fou contre les
cavaliers parce que si tu changes les
tours et tu joues à four va préférer les
3 x 3 dans le 3e set final avec dame
quand même mal pour les blancs non oui
si tu te ra c'est pour ça qu'il veut pas
échangé jeudi en échangeant les tours et
un chargeur le col et contrefous cette
finale est complètement est-ce que l'on
peut jouer pour alors faut préparer
parce que c'est pas évident mais si on
réussit à faire j'ai quatre les noirs
ont pas accès à la case f4 en tout cas
difficilement et nous on est à deux
coups réponse les lombrics en rappel de
feindre la peur g4 tu vas attention ça
s'est super bien joué fourchette 1
pourquoi le prends pas le pion à
peut-être tour d2 bien tordre et aurait
deux oui c'est une éminent tour d2 savez
la rivière fois cette chape marché pour
prendre la foudre ou encore j'ai un bon
que c'est les noirs qui vont se
retrouver mieux à force
bah ça se passe toujours comme ça
maintenant il faut jouer peut-être dans
le ciel de poindre un g4 faut comprendre
accueille d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'elle jouera mon ami 6 dans le ciel de
quand même tu vois roger 6
ça c'est le genre de truc avec les
blancs je perds tout le temps c'est
tellement dur à jouer à partir de là il
ya un point encore une fois il n'ya pas
d'objectifs clairs définis tapote de
faiblesse dans le corps de noir est bon
là c'est égal surtout oui tu perds pas
le truc mais maintenant tu perds en
quarts des dépenses d'âme un échec
mais bon je pense que la wii mahatta
cavalli et 4 dames 2 qui épreuve de dame
prend dame de france et 4 d'accord et
jacques a peut-être gagné les deux oui
dany par gagner quelque chose quoi
attention quand même alors elle a un
petit contre la dame csn secteur huawei
adan mejias dans les desserts les 5 ha
mince hautes chaumes dame pointe cette
dame à qui est le seul qu'officier sous
la forme incroyable qu'elle m'a grave tu
veux maintenant ou des 5s il a raté un
elle était vraiment mieux je pense que
le dernier en dames 4 au moment où elle
a raté ça lui simplifier tellement la
vie mais attends mais tu les vois cette
rue canon seconde de ce sujet je n'ai
même pas vu le coup sur l'échiquier midi
des jeunes d'amiante d'avocats toi comme
dit youssef il se fâche à cause des m&a
libéral mais j'ai besoin de réfléchir ça
se comprend le truc tu vois c'est que je
suis mauvais en ouverture pas super en
stratégie faut que j'ai quand même
quelque chose pour moi parce que sinon
je perdrais vraiment toutes mes parts
c'est mon unique point fort tu vas genre
la dame b 4 dames b2c genre de truc que
je vois vite ici est ce cas pourquoi un
show pas d'henri iv
c'était un père blanc et peut-être ces
trois dames bd ou quoi mais sur ce genre
de petit acquis que je vois rien oui je
pense je pense mais je peux te dire
comment j'ai fait pour voir que ce que
j'ai fait pour voir vite les tactiques
comme ça qu'est ce que tu achètes langue
étrangère
quand j'étais adolescent oui faisait
trois heures d'entraîneur tactique par
jour qu'est ce que c'est un
impressionnant
l'équivalent des puzzles rush souder des
tactiques sur chaise comme ce que dans
l'absolu si je peux reprocher quelque
chose va pas aurait encore une fois de
plus à une c'est une opinion personnelle
c'est que certains traînent la vision de
tactique mais certaines positions sont
tellement artificiel je ne suis pas sûr
que notre cerveau y perçoit ces deux
comme ces positions l'a parfois ne
peuvent pas forcément à rêver sur
l'échiquier
je me dis notre cerveau ne le perçoit
pas de la même façon ça peut être même
néfaste web après la fin mais à l'époque
c'était vrai je faisais un peu tout je
faisais des livres des machins et c'est
pour ça que je suis dit puzzle rush
entraîneur tactique je faisais un peu de
tout mais je faisais trois heures par
jour fait cinq six jours par semaine
moins génial j'ai j'aime beaucoup faire
les exercices
moi je m'entraîne surtout avec des
livres et là avant la coupe du monde je
me dis il marester semaine les forêts
que je sache et face à petit stage
d'entraînement alors moi c'est très
important c'est vraiment efficace et
beaucoup de faire ça marche vraiment
bien mais après ça fait pas progresser
globalement c'est bien si tu veux être
fort en blitz en fait situé en longue ça
peut être pas trop en réalité de faire
ça oui moi j'ai fait pas mal d exil
d'exercice stratégique
j'aime beaucoup aussi les livres est de
devoir éthique et oui mais j'ai quand je
me suis entraîné avec alexander scheer
ninon se concentrait plus voilà sur les
exercices stratégique qui est sans
forcément travailler sur les ouvertures
qui était d'améliorer un milieu de jeu
ça fait très longtemps que j'ai pas fait
ça longtemps
et alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans la
partie je crois que ça c'est moi j'aime
beaucoup la position était plein ben oui
là il ya le centre il ya le fou qui est
moche à la casse des cats qui va arriver
camp rock comme tu disais un peu plus
tôt on voit que willy fans c'est plus du
tout une joueuse pro 1 parce que elle
est beaucoup plus fort que enfin sens
est beaucoup plus fort que ting j mais
son niveau en préparation dans les
ouvertures il est bien en dessous
aujourd'hui
l'un pour celui de problèmes européens
non je pense que c'est l'idée je peux
juste mettre le roi à l'abri du froid
bien mais en même temps revient à hawaï
je me suis dit peut-être a4 et a5 ça va
arriver un jour je sais qu elles ferment
mais il joue quand même en rien c'est
une idée vrai je pense qu'elle a raison
d'y fermer parce qu'elle veut pas donner
la case aux cavaliers oui mais en même
temps tu vas tu faire mais bon c'est
tellement facile pour les glandus et
dans ses positions la l5 si tu le joues
avec la main ah mais je pense que dans
tous les cas elle est juste un objet
qu'il est mal à la fois quatre dames à 3
attention peut-être faire un 4 mais t'as
pas envie oui mais peut-être tu dois pas
ce que ton fou il va quand même être
bien installé et comment les noirs le
déloge ça va être long le terrain andré
fossé siècle donc probablement à 4 tout
à fait raison en fait j'ai obligé même
obligés de rouler j'ai dit oui mais
c'est comme ça qu'on voit en fait
comment les joueurs d'échecs pro7
j'essaie dans les mécanismes de prise de
décision c'est intéressant de le voir et
je pense que c'est pas si mal de le
décortiquer même pour nous je vous dis
je ne joue pas forcément toute cette
position là j'ai besoin de comprendre
alors qu'est ce qui se passe ici
comment le roi oui mais le pion h là il
va faire très mal
tu as fait rage si ce qui a valu à 5 qui
a rédigé cette ou h 6 tours h 4 min
pratiquement obligé de jouer au 8 mais
là en fait le fouillis joue jamais oui
et c'est normal c'est terminé annoncer
cette institution partie affreuse je
sais pas tu vas si la domination totale
des pièces blanches
je suis surtout ravi c'est que j'essaie
de facile est-ce qu'elle n'a combien de
partis restent étiez sûr sur cette
cadence
il veut en rester 2 derrière celle là
peut-être partie à trois points d'écart
le match est pas gagné encore un regard
c'est beau le roi il sort pas quoi c'est
magnifique et même temps certain plaisir
esthétique avoir cette position là parce
qu'on les voit rarement
ah bah oui bon je sais que j'ai le
niveau
j'ai dix ans et plus les partis
classiques le niveau de la résistance la
même et voilà c'est vraiment un cours de
deux placements de quel seuil à égalité
matérielle mais et quelle domination
c'est très intéressant alors des jo
copiale non non non fougueux 5
je pense qu'elle va retourner dans la
non là on allait retourner dans la
berlinoise que c'était quand même pas si
ça c'est pas super bien passé la
dernière à la finit par la gagner mais
mais elle est passée par une position
vraiment difficile
oui mais en même temps peut-être qu'elle
s'est dit peut-être que s'est aperçu
qu'il était assez lent je suivais ses
positions la c1 ce facile à jouer c'est
ton plan qu'avait les deux tours rien
autour de 1 quel effet quel j'ai trois
fois quatre officiers de au p4 tout
dépend mais c'est tellement facile à
jouer pour les blancs ces briques c'est
ça ça représente pas une grande
difficulté il y a une des idées très
intéressant très intéressante dans cette
position là c'est pour ça que les blancs
jour ou g5 d'ailleurs je pense parce que
quand j'ai analysé les mêmes structures
l'idée de jouer cavalier 8 cavell et des
six si tu vas pour les noirs d'être est
extrêmement intéressante il aurait placé
le cavalier c'est bien évidemment pas
avec leur le clouage mais c'est très
intéressante pour ça que will find jour
où j'ai 5
oui pour empêcher ben gluck et le diarra
djila homos c'est toujours les mêmes
positions dans la partie précédente et
peut-être à métisser sdige et il va
rejouer j'ai ça que je vais prendre un
g5
ouais
elle répète pas tout à l'heure il y
avait qu il y avait eu échange en c4
avant mais elle a clairement amélioré
voilà elle a dû comprendre que fout g500
un problème et donc de couper quatre
très bons coups il voulait pas prendre à
bab échange des tours à peut-être
maintenant qui a value c'est pas une
très bonne manoeuvre mais ce que je peux
je devais gcc c'est le faut et h 4g par
la vie mais bon je me suis dit moi je
n'arrive pas à évaluer ses positions là
je suis incapable j'ai l'impression que
les blancs sont mieux et à chaque fois
je me fais compterait donc j'ai compris
que je ne comprenais pas c'est un tout
petit peu mieux certes je suis
l'impression d'être mieux je me retrouve
toujours comme dans la finale de tout à
l'heure la contrée pour foutu genre sans
jamais comprendre pourquoi mais parce
que cette finale là avec les points qui
sont sur les cases noires et les
complètement égal si t'arrives par
exemple l'a joué beckett a4 a5 qui est
le plan stratégique des blancs dans
cette position là là c'est finalement ça
va mieux mais la city arrive pas ça va
tourner pour les noirs dont il va y
avoir foule g4 est saturé il va se
passer exactement ce qui m'arrive à
chaque fois qu'est ce qui s'est passé et
l'a pris à des jeux qu'elle 4.464 des 5
oui ça va j'ai l'impression donc ça
devient dur pour les blancs petit à
petit pour le moment ça va je pense que
oui c'est ça qui va arriver eux
s'installent fonds d'ici ce talent et
psion vincent d'indy
on a envie de jouer c'est kate je dirais
avec les blancs mais je me suis posé la
question du gcc 4 c 5 peut-être même tu
vois je je vais te démolir complètement
cette chaîne de pions et il crée le clan
passé j'ai envie de jouer c'est 4 mais
peut-être que c'est tout simplement pas
possible
oui je suppose je pense que c'est une
très bonne réaction des c4 c5 a lieu
cinq maintenant tu vas être obligé de
remettre le camion age 2 apparaît tel
monde durant 5
oui la lâcher d'accord un regard de la
casse ces quatre aussi comment tu
protèges t'as pas envie de réveiller des
2es et l'un qui veut rester 4.361 jour
tu as dû cavaler f3 d'armes français 3
elle va revenir à deux points un peu
comme tout à l'heure thing jl père mais
elle réussit à ceux à rester concentré à
rester dans le match qui est dur à faire
un pas ce que tu peux vraiment coulé et
tu vois c'est ça la différence entre les
jouets ce qui arrive en demi-finale et
les premiers tours il vous deviez tout
en fait à une joueuse qui lâche et et
comme c'est moins fort tu vois c'est pas
du top mondial
sara lee complètement et là quand arrive
en fin de compétition un peu comme
milliards dans le match d'arica et katia
en fait là les joueuses elle l'a jamais
quoi lasser oui c'est pas du tout le
même niveau en fait mais encore une fois
c'est le niveau de la résistance qui est
un cas crois et je pensais aux couches
ou bien il le fait avec une idée
complètement improbables je voulais
replacer l'oeuf ou 1 1 à 2 c il faut
faire quelque chose dans cette position
là et qui t'a donné un pion mais
peut-être ici c'était on peut activer
les pièces ce que je crois que les trois
dames 6 3 on va voir tour des 3 x 2 et
il faut faire quelque chose
elle prend le pion et tour des trois
récits je pense est assez bien joué de
sa part uni fans c'est vrai que ce pion
c'est le moins important des trois au
final comme ces deux regarde quelle idée
à moi c'était plus avec l'idée de créer
cette batterie mais un petit peu fou
prend les 3 es fou ou 5 du coût pour
bloquer pour blic pour empêcher l'idée
pour toi c'est naturel parce que je
n'aurais pas envisager ça tout de suite
tu vas j'aurais par les âges et de
donald la perte de fouet tu vois le fait
probablement oui
ouais ça j'aurais pensé aux fous
jécistes je sais tout de suite
j'aurais pensé avec jef au b2i ici il
faut que deux tu sais ça les plombs à 1
à 3 les protéger donc tu vois il avait
placé maintenant s'en fout 1 à 2 il est
sale et offrait de belles chances de
défense même si jusqu à un moment donné
je vais avoir il n'ya pas du f3 ici qui
rôde aussi c'était madame arrivant le 5
3 en fait j'aurais pas jouer ça en me
disant que c'est c'est fort au patch est
en fait quand je joue plus kambly
desouhant rapide j'ai que des réflexes
pour jouer de manière pratique en fait
est juste de manière pratique ça me
paraissait bon genre life 3 puis on
prend d'un match 2 c'est ce que je vois
en premier pas si c'est bon mais ça me
paraît logique parce qu'elle joue et je
pense que ça doit gagner un lainage
ouais quand c'est fini c'est plus des
réflexes de blitz en fait non je
pratique et réactif oui c'est très
important de les avoir je me rends
compte que j'ai pas du tout ses réflexes
là est peut-être en prévision de
quelques portes yens départager il
faudrait que je vois là que je me
prépare les jeux j'écoute attentivement
j'ai besoin de quelques conseils pour
apprendre d'un match 2 d'un rêve de tour
en d3 ouais en plus c'est pas que la
qualité qualité attaques de maths et
elle revient à deux points il reste quoi
il restera il reste une partie et jamais
je pense qu'elle doit s que j'allais
dire faut qu'elles jouent des castings
il faut qu'elle reste là dessus faut pas
qu'elle aille sur les répète pas la
catalane malicieux 4 faut aller là
dessus parce que je pourrais vous il
réfléchit tu vas et c'est exactement et
ne pouvait pas répéter cette variante
s'il était trop passive donc là choisi
mais sauver quatre échecs 2 je suis en
train de me dire qu'on bullet hell peut
faire tellement mal parce que en fait
oui fans on voit qu'elle est moins bien
classée en bullet et ça en plus les
catalanes c'est le genre de position
parfaite à jouer en bullet avec les
blancs parce que ses positions et à
petit avantage tu peux jouer facilement
plus vite que ton adversaire et août à
cette petite pression à long terme c'est
très agréable à jouer en bullet ces
trucs là et gérer leurs contrats quand
alain il faut jouer un rôle est échangé
le système avec ses sièges c'est là où
c'est complètement différent
oui oui je suis 100% d'accord avec toi
faut qu'il joue un autre système si elle
rentre dans ce genre de positions en
bullet elle va juste perdre du temps
dans l'ouverture elle va se retrouver
avec 50 secondes contre 20 elle aura
peut-être égaliser mais mais mais mais
thing j en fais tu sais j'ai
l'impression que c'est une vraie blitz
aux en fait tu me lis ça sent elle est
vraiment forte en blitz est comme moi
que je suis en train de me poser la
question comment on récupère les pions
un siège comprend un g3 j'ai peur de
prendre large et trois fois mais
peut-être de reculer pour iphone à foix
cette capacité cfc 65.5 vous prenez car
oui mais elle veut contre je n'en sais
intéressant qu'est ce que la météo j'ai
trois peut-être qu'on avait force est
également mais je récupère rd4 quand
même après donc j'ai trois mois j'avais
l'impression je pensais je sais pas quel
était le coût mais je pense que c'était
âge j'ai bêtement et kf3 mais bon il y
avait eu six fois fc est un qui se
regardent et elle a pris et maintenant
cavalier
attention quand même parce que c'est
quoi c'est un pur ouais mais c'est un
énorme qu en fait ce que ces cinq
comptes de ses deux pions plus est ces
cinq comptes de chèques et en plus ces
deux puces ouhlala tu fais pousser
ouais j'ai surtout sa hanche droite
protège tu menaces les changes des dames
il n'y a pas d'âme e66 à cavalli g5
c'est un fiasco là et sur d'amd et là je
pensais dam des trois là dessus
ah non
détroit ya dame prend et on marque trois
pardon non non tu peux pas jouer dans le
métro ce que je voulais dire je n'ai
acheté en train de réfléchir sur comment
la vallée g5 donc fouache trois
peut-être amené la tour et elle a bien
joué à ou parce que ça aurait pu perdre
j'essaie surtout des buts je me suis dit
avec les dettes je vais pour est roi
mais malheureusement il ya donc deux
trois petits sets ce coup
ouais ben 8 c'est vrai tu aimes bien je
pensais qu'elle est joe torre 8
est ce que ça peut arriver quand tu as
vu au début cavaliers g5 n'est pas
possible à cause de dames g2 de le rater
genre 5 ou plus tarder un moment donné
craquer le faire aujourd'hui ça s'oublie
oui j'oubliais que yavin et et aux
menaces d'un premier set qui avait
déjoué cinq fois dans l'es3 comme très
bien joué et d'un bep ctc du coup n'est
plus possible donc aux deux tours f3
qu'elle est obligée de garder la dame
des trois tours d un faux ici pourquoi
prendre un set
elle veut revenir avec food et saint
caprais mais t'es tu pourras faire tout
reprendre et 5 un jour même parce que tu
as quand même trois pions oui mais
c'était à west est une variante très
concrètes qu'elle jugeait tu sais quoi
en blitz
je me demande si c'est pas égal mais
genre enfin bien équilibré puisque c'est
sûr qu'en longue les blancs sont mieux
parce que là davantage mata elle est
trop important mais en blitz
il ya tellement de problèmes pratiques
et je me suis posé la question en fait
t'as raison de le mentionner est ce que
dans le paramètre en fait dans
l'algorithme de l'évaluation on pouvait
rentrer des paramètres que ses autres
que le paramètre absolue mathématiques
tu vois c'est ce que je voulais dire ils
allaient sacré fait en f3 et elle veut
créer le chaos dans nos temps tu vois la
force de joueurs ça c est ce que ça peut
jouer ce serait bien ça ce serait
ça reste un de leurs devoirs ci interdit
food et 5 et menace d'un me 2 qui chasse
complètement la dame et surtout acheté 5
donc comment faire si c'est très bien
joué de la part de team gym elle joue
super bien là à 7-7 un sacré chez
spéculatifs bon et elle a raison et la
raison de le faire maintenant comment
comment continuer tu sais c'est pas si
grave
à quatre tours a fuité s'il regarde une
nouvelle fois le temps comme on est près
du corps vers ça y est j'y crois je suis
à jour h vite mais d'un mètre d'eux
quand même et deux à temps il y avait un
big blue et il faisait 4 puis ça suffit
pour des trois lamelles cinq dames c6
d'un des trois dames 8 dames le 6 mai
c'est pour ça que je voulais j'ai
torréfié ça me plaisait pas c'est au
départ je voulais bouger mon cavalier
mais la tour est en prise donc très bien
jouer tout simplement passé c'est trop
c'est trop pour une seule femme la
victoire très convaincante pour revenir
autour des 8 n'importe quel rêve vient
en secours - revient à un point et c'est
la fin des bullet y avait 4 2 c'est la
fin des pardons des trois minutes et
elle elle revient à un point donc il ya
qu'un point d'écart à présent entre les
deux joueuses y avait plus 4 elle avait
une meilleure position ou donc elle est
à deux doigts de faire + 5 et et à la
partie elle a perdu par dont 3 trois
parties consécutives et là tu vois je
pense que avec toutes les formations
coach m'a donné je pense que l'été est
clairement une baisse de régime et et on
voit avec les ouvertures
le truc en bus c'est très bizarre mais
on bulle est d'avoir vraiment de très
mauvaises ouverture c'est tracy
vraiment pas bien parce que si tu es mal
c'est dur de jouer vite en fait c'était
vraiment très mal et latines xvi elle a
tellement pris l'ascendant dans les
ouvertures que ça me paraît très
inquiétant pour pour où je pense qu'elle
doit retourner dans la berlinoise ou
dans la finale où elle pourra jouer vite
et espérer avec les noirs d'avoir une
petite arme pour pour sortir avec les
noirs aussi je me suis dit est ce que ce
sera possible que par exemple couillet
fine elle adopte une ouverture gens là
la pire que mais même toujours en fait
tu dois je voulais vite donc tu fais les
courges et si ce projet les joue pas
elle joue palestinienne si c'est un vrai
problème
je sais pour son répertoire c'est que je
suis ouverture là mais j'ai 6 2 7 6 qui
avait levé cette allure et elle qui sait
qui tu as joué vite
oui oui oui et une gaffe pas forcément
dans ses positions de part je pense que
c'est ce qu'il a fait aux jeux de ton
adversaire et je sais ce qu'elle doit
faire almirola pas trop le choix mon
avion
c'est une très bonne stratégie et je me
suis dit qu'est ce que j'aurais fait je
je me prépare je sais pour un match que
vous voulez tête faute éthique dans
quelques années ou j'oserais je me suis
dit je n'ai rien d'autre à faire que des
déchets quelle énorme boulette qui le
tranquille il ya déjà baky qui m'a battu
n'ya pas longtemps en bullet permettre
comment ça s'est passé
bah en fait c'est parti d'un délire où
on joue contre bas qui à un moment donné
il veut faire 2-3 bullet et jeux géants
jeux lengagne six d'affilée tu vois ben
on me dit c'est il m'a dit je vais me
préparer
j'aurais pas dû accepter la revanche je
veux dire tout de suite baky préparer en
bullet
il m'a fait très très mal c'est préparer
il s'est acheté une souris la joue en
bullet et où il était hyper très serré
c'est très important
oui voilà il après pas il s'est préparé
à 200% et ça ça s'est pas très bien
passé non il est fort le petit
à mon avis il s'agit surtout d'une d'une
vraie blessure narcissique alors ça
pouvait pas se passer comme ça apporte
une victoire non j'ai compris qu'il
aurait mieux fallu que j'en laisse 2 3
tu vois j'aurais dû gagner 4 200 recttes
et mieux je vais pas y aller trop fort
là j'ai compris que c'était une très
mauvaise idée et baky préparé aucune
chance à beaucoup trop fort il s'est
préparé contre la scandinave à tort elle
restera bien raison c'est l'heure du
goûter en plus j'ai ouï mais moi j'aime
épauler le temps de déjeuner dans
peut-être passé les horaires qui ne sont
pas forcément adaptés aux commentateurs
et moi non plus j'ai prévu de déjeuner
juste après en fait à la fin ultime j tu
as le morcellement du chocolat elle est
contente elle a l'air très confirme je
pense qu elle cédé le plus dur est fait
ouais ah si je vais finir le match mais
je vais lâcher je voulais dire ça mais
bon tu vois c'est un match tu aimais
n'est pas si évidente d'utiliser les
expressions que s'expriment en dur mais
ardu relative elle est allé très très
dur là tu penses à dureté non
et qu'on se montrait encore là mais tu
as raison c'est ça ce sont les images de
plus en plus disputée ouais le niveau de
jeu qu'en plus le niveau de jeu augmente
et tu vois qu'elle se lève elle se
laisse vraiment pas sombrer oui fans en
sueur les parties elle va pas mon avis
elle elle a perdu le match aux femmes on
va voir à mon avis elle a perdu dans
cette phase là elle n'a pas bien géré
elle a pris l'avantagé au lieu de tuer
le match et l'a mal gérée
on va voir façon 20 on va avoir la
réponse rapidement quand je me suis dit
un molière aurait dit quoi quelle phase
et leur a laissé les airs à la place des
halles va l'achever
aaaah ça me ce qui parlait vraiment le
même français que nous c'est comme un
livre
je sais que les livres qu'on lit de
molière ils sont réadapter déjà oui
évidemment mais c'est pour ça que hier
c'était un petit clin d'oeil parce que
tout le monde sait que je suis
absolument juste tellement éprise de la
poésie de baudelaire sa chair adapter un
peu c'était un clin d'oeil à la poésie à
l'auteur que j'aime beaucoup mais est ce
qu'il ya une manière élégante de dire
qu'on va l'achever
je suis dit qu'il y avait là trucider
devons être lucides et c'est possible
comme terme 75 ans dans le registre de
cette entrée que oui fait longtemps que
j'ai pas lu molière ça remonte à mon
adolescence je me rappelle plus tôt fait
partie encore une fois de nom oui c'est
obligatoire malades d'imaginaire s'est
référé à ça c'est marrant j'aime
beaucoup le comique de situation
et des phrases parfait sorti de nulle
part te dis mais comment j'allais j'aime
tellement les mots que la beauté des
phrases par femme surprend est ce qu'on
peut dire je vais l'oblitérer avec papa
avec le public est oblitéré serait faire
disparaître effacé vrai je vais
l'oblitérer ça peut être pas mal verbe
transitif faire disparaître effacés
maintenant je comprends oui parce que
j'ai tellement pas l'habitude des vrais
streaming tu vois j'ai compris que les
uns souvent lien bas les maux de tête on
appelle ça plus un modérateur ou comment
plus un présentateur qu'on partage
l'écran avec toute la communauté
voilà on ne partageait pas avec eux nous
allons partager pas avec la commune et
ont regardé de notre côté on peut se
passer mais ça arrive qu'on partage avec
la commune ont regardé juste oblitéré ce
que ça voulait dire exactement ça me
semble être un terme possible mais c'est
bien la première fois j'aime cédé que
sur cette chaîne on commence à discuter
c'est sur le choix des mots ça c'est
avec des images qui qui sont qui
s'attache au moût forcément alors fausse
et captura djoko piano je t'avais dit
oui tout dire qu'elle va perdre
non c'est quand même sur mais tu voyais
elle reste encore une fois fidèle à ce
plan avec à cinq ici tu vas j'ai calé
dès 2010 et des de prendre mais quel est
des deux caves et des fins et très
simple à jouer
oui ça c'est du grand classique ça c'est
cool a joué pour les noirs en bullet en
vrai parce que tu pousses à l'endroit et
attaque plus facilement réussi le terme
de l'afjv elle efface est pas mal aussi
ça comme terme à les chasser ça ça doit
être la traduction d'une expression
russe at schiste non ce serait plus
assisté de ses différents j'avais des
unités logistiques est beaucoup plus dur
c'est pas mal aussi mais là tu vois
c'est les positions je sais pas qui est
mieux mais avoir un cavalier en f4 en
bullet avec du cavalier pranger aut 2e
du calibrage 3 qui rôdent c'est juste
fantastique mais c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il garde dans mon coin je
pensais qu'il allait faire le pas lent
typique mais elle a obligé de garder
alors ce tandem de cavale et que l'aide
des deux caves élèves 3 qui pour le
moment un pêche totale calcul cavaliers
g23 prend et qui arrive et prend des
cats je pense qu'elle essaie de faire
marcher un truc comme ça a c'est super
joli point f2 aller mater ce que tu as
et c'est tellement dangereux mais c'est
pas sûr que cas cette pièce non c'est
pas sûr que ça marche mais je veux dire
tu sens qu'avec les blancs ça va être ça
va être complexe
c'est si tu peux petit en bullet tu peux
pas laisser un truc comme ça et des
menaces latentes surtout moins en partie
la raison là je comprends qu'elle
devienne pas aux classes et oui fans qui
a très bien négocié en fait il ya eu un
petit coup de réussite pour yifan c'est
que ça donnait l'impression que quelque
chose marché pour les noirs elle a rien
trouvé à laquelle a gâché 25 secondes
ça c'est une question de réussite après
un dans le but est évidemment il ya un
goûter chaud il laisse comme point elle
venait jouer quelle est la baisse est
même tombé 4 est urgent de poser la
question va les cavaliers charretour
épisode de f cell et allait pas bien là
objectivement mais le truc c'est que ça
reste difficile à convertir pour les
blancs oui mais tu vois c'est très bien
joué
roche 2 j'ai trois rouages et 2d sur
défendre le club se positionne helmand
pour moi c'est un gros avantage est ce
qu'elle peut le défendre
voilà oui fans elle fait enfin elle a un
melon est là je trouve un peu de
réussite et elle a très bien joué elle a
eu un petit peu de réussite sur une
phase vous saurez plus vraiment vraiment
vraiment perdre et après elle a vraiment
bien enchaîner et là il ya les c4 qui
arrivent aussi oui donc à l'équipe d4 a
laissé pas fait encore à l'étymologie
oil et oil et oui phalangistes pas là
pour etienne
bon je préfère que l'erreur de la finale
oui les fans y as tu veux pas voir tim j
non je me suis dit en fait j'ai sacré
lisent beaucoup les choses tu sais aux
échecs et gm dit avoir la meilleure
joueuse du monde
un final c'est pour moi c'est très
important
en tout cas on tient là c'est en train
de pas très bien se passer pour wii fans
sur les derniers coups il ya toutes les
cages angie qui arrivent mais elle est
plus de seconde allait il faut qu'elle
joue et faut qu'elle arrive à protéger
toutes ces pièces en touraine déchets
pour bien jouer la protéger latourelle
mais attend une cavalière 3 qui arrive
et il ya dames quatre noms qui compte au
nom pourquoi la pureté d'un vieux
cartable et 5 elle est un peu prendre
l'été
olala dames 4 ça sentait bon amarrée à
l'iss est en train de primes ou 24 là
c'est n'importe quoi
voyage 3 aussi terrible très bien c'est
du hasard là c'est du hasard total gabon
d'alain giresse a concentré parce que
oui laquelle des 6 et 7 6 8 a assez
c'était du clic au hasard là est ce
qu'il n'ya de prénom est encore possible
qu est-ce qu on peut assez bien joué
band et si ça tu vois c'était du total
hasard mais à gagner pour iphone ça fait
mal a thing j 7 défaites en france à
cliquer au hasard quand même admira là
mais j'ai déjà du mal c'est un chaos qui
règne sur l'échiquier je me suis dit que
mes pièces vol mais c'est vraiment c'est
marrant quand sakic un peu statique un
peu de partout c'est cool oui mais il
faut que tu m'as dit que la direction
alors je sais plus où il ferait bien
rire pas trop direction il ya des ya des
pièces qui partent un peu de partout
mais en tout cas ça c'est une position
qui réserverait très bien tu voir sa
clique la sakic pas assez encore mais
très bien joué pour pas
très bien négocié cette ouverture par
foyer fans et surtout prendre 4 comprend
d'amd 3 termine à dos à ça j'ai pas vu
et uf6 est obligé de prendre un
assaillant avait du coup tu pourrais je
sais tu prend 1,5 et tu vas thing j en
fait dans le petit jeu tactique
elle est très très forte qu'est ce que
tu peux faire aussi un cave et les
citoyens ou intérêts sans bien jouer
bien jouer en même temps elle a perdu 20
secondes ont bien mangé leurs pions
prend 1,4 et occasions même nom oui et
quatre copains - ouais c'est une
position désespérée avec 50 secondes à
tandis que j'imagine pour des blancs
dont il voulait quand même un petit peu
encore on sait jamais ça peut cliquer ou
bienvenue tu as écrit à tour 6 1 étoile
récupère récupérant de fermer les six
accords c'est pas fini fille encore on
va dire elle c'est un vrai combat de
boxe ça j'ai l'impression que en fait
combien de doran des ja ouais mais c'est
bien parce que tu as tu as besoin en
bulles est de faire travailler les
adversaires de pas donné de point facile
c'est important ce qui est en train de
faire là bas de pas complètement craqué
équation une partie qu'elle va prendre
la tour et le client baissier je ne sais
plus où donner la tête et un des cinq
noms des cinq à mon avis simple est
rentré dans la finale ouais mais bon tu
as vingt secondes 20 secondes chacune
elle a bien calculé qui est rien ah oui
bon 6 à 6,6 à foug prendre un tour froid
ici d'algérois h3 la calculer il ya rien
elle repart en elles vont en acheter
trois ok mais parce que tu avais
toujours stores dame s'est vite tu avais
un les achats qualité leopard en main ce
qu'elle a fait elle aurait pu vrai
prendre la tour en 1 et pas s'embêter en
avoir deux quoi complètement gagnant oui
bien sûr mais ça aurait pu quoi
coquelles et les gc ces chèques
ah ouais mais le truc c'est rick d'aidé
quoi tout recouvre en fait ça contre
échec mais rodez est quand même endroit
dès qu'un roi c4 puis elle va faire
tourner trois maintenant et après roy b5
échec bien jouer à 4 assez bien joué
mais tu vois cinq secondes farhat ou peu
tard fin tout peut arriver
cavalier seul est un comme mon ami avant
que roy b4 franchement c'était pas loin
de tourner un jeu direct angie a surtout
un jeu comprend pas comment elle a pas
pris la tour ça aurait permis de passer
sans le sacrifice y en a 2 h doit être
terminée tout de suite la partie et
finalement c'est un prix move peut-être
parce que s'attendaient à un échec je
fais là s'est passé quand même alors
attends il reste combien de temps parce
que là les partis sont guéris déjà plus
que 16 minutes donc y aura pas
énormément de partis cdu marty à 60
coups là qu'on vient de voir la crise il
serait tombé dans la même structure sûr
que oui les fans il a ajouté 4 ici il a
préféré je veux des quatre tout de suite
en 3 1 cécile d'un coup que je voulais
mentionner dans notre portier souvent
les noirs je vous des 5.5 déstabilise le
centre de cette façon là il paraît avec
les mêmes idées que vale h quatre
cavaliers 5 4 elle va refaire dame huit
touristes cinq belges et 6 allons
repartir dans le même truc c'est sûr ici
il faut toujours aussi fier gaiffe bon
bien fait il est dans cette position là
mais si le club où j'ai un sacrifice de
qualité pour f3 voilà exactement dans
cette optique là si les dames revient à
5 qu'elle défend par exemple cache toi
je sais pas tord f3 il ya plein d des
tactiques
protège encore une fois les vides qui
avait les détroits kireev de risque oui
donc là avec toutes les flèches j'en
sais plus qui je vais d'abord un sac
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire enfin elle
découvre bien en faire mais c'est pas
possible
non en fait oui fans à elle fait un truc
enfin en fait les deux sont assez c'est
assez bien ce qu'elles font partie
musique qui veut vraiment attaquer le
roi parce qu'elle sait qu en bullet
c'est positif
oui j'ai l'impression que weezy fans
allaient préparer contre cette idée là
elle a une position où tout est très
bien protégé géré par là que les deux
joueuses veulent rentrer dans un style
et un mais je pense que tu as écrit les
fans elle s'est posée la question est
que cette façon de surprotéger ces
pièces tu essaies de faire très
attention en gaf 1 d'un coup et elles
seront très importantes
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et pas
compris pourquoi la paperie henri vii
avant pour bouffer l'autre cavaliers ça
j'ai pas j'ai pas si je pense que
c'était 1-1 elle s'enferme dans un style
là tim gyger qu'elle veut vraiment
attaquer l aile réajuste pas son style
en fait elle veut jouer pour faire maths
alors qu'elle pourrait aller faucher 5g
katla ya pas de ces jeux avec mes
cavaliers gyan quand même tour 6-3 aussi
en même temps les coûts sont simples tu
vas tu es tu reviens avec la tour en c3
et il protège la troisième est ton g3
parfait mais c'est très très bien vu de
la part de et d'un programme 3,3 g 2
tout est posé c'est très bien vu de la
part de ou en fait de vraiment tout
défendre et encore ce à quoi le roi
shaka langue dans mes six as well as
lecavalier lecavalier devant un roi
c'est toujours bien placé pour défendre
mais bon à la raison de l'ajout et team
là ça va gagner et le truc c'est que les
partis sont très longues il va pas elle
veut échanger les dames c'est pas bête
fait à 9,7 du coup j'essaie d'en bas
comme si le roi g3 ici il n'ya pas une
partie facile on n'a pas une partie
facile là il ya deux points d'écart et
il reste douze minutes
il reste quatre parties normalement mais
ça va il s'en sort pas si mal
enfin tu vois elle rentre pas dans les
catalanes maintenant ils veulent à
transposer dans une vigne et avec chez
trois mois ya les aider avec fouille 5
et 4 et 6 donc lieu joue exactement et
il empêche donc éviter de vous faites ça
empêche cet échange cavaliers ou quatre
sites une aide et stratégiques
alors qu'il prend et quatre non
intermédiaire où il ya quand même des f4
ici et je me suis dit peut-être qu'elle
veut jouer avec un centre tu sais c'est
quelque chose à prendre affronte danger
au parti boulettes et si ça c'est sympa
ça c'est tout à fait comme quand on
parlait des catalanes où je dis c'est
sympa à jouer avec les blancs c'est
comme tu as beaucoup de cases autant
parfois quand tu as beaucoup de temps tu
sais pas trop comment faire parce que
t'as rien ou percer autant là tu veux
juste jouer des coups sont vraiment
d'idée bon là l idée mais je deviens tu
peux juste place était pièce tu as
beaucoup de cases
je vais admirer les pièces blanches
domine complètement déjoué cinq et
maintenant elle se tient le centre par
f4 à la
oui oui avec avaler des six qui est
arrivé du coup maintenant peut-être
tourné en b 5e v1 5 n'y en a pas
évoque-t-elle garder les croisiens j'ai
trouvé ça un peu spécial
qu'est-ce qu'elle a joué et joue 3g un
crachin laura était bien attendu peut
mettre le fond j'ai deux à tout moment
auquel a voulu envie de cette diagonale
mais bon d'un autre côté c'est vrai que
cette impression alors le dernier coup
on a fait n'importe quoi avec les blancs
il faut juste faire qu'à radio 4 qui a
aidé systran qu'il suive son idée m est
bienvenue tu veux dire que tu voulais
garder cette facette armada des pions
sans tabac juste mettre le cavalier là
bas et je chante forcer un peu les
changes défaut attaqué la tour et
continue à avancer et c'est vrai que
c'est vous qui arrivez à ces cinq
regarde aller où la dame repris 6,5
c'est vrai qu'elle regarde le temps
aussi elle a pris beaucoup de temps pour
jouer des coups un peu bizarre mais ça
c'est la fatigue
honnêtement c'est 100% fatigué damas 3
pouces et funk
elle reprend la main je garde bien vrai
qu'il est l'arrêté querellé g4
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ces dames h4
on se comprend dame ces trois noms car
oui à l'aide d'armes chez toi moi je
pensais 3 voilà du coup ces pièces de
plus haut relate à deux écoles tu peux
aller sacrifier faut faire gaffe parce
que ça ça peut encore tourner un hommage
à tanja tout ce que c'est tout changer
alors là ça peut changer vite ça joue
vite on sait pas froide
c'est un coup magnifique byron de c'est
bizarre j'ai appris à [ __ ] en d5 en
fait depuis tout à l'air froid hi5 elles
ont raté pendant
ce la marche de du mana mais je sais pas
si c'est vraiment justifié après je dis
franchement j'aurais raté aussi si c'est
moi qui jouais sais juste que quand tu
es spectateurs et n'a pas à jouer les
coups c'est beaucoup plus facile de voir
quand tu joues en fait était été pris
dans le créneau dans l'engrenage étape
le temps de voir la position tu veux
juste par réflexe genre là ça masque et
prend ses cahiers sait si c'est un tour
de plus après mes bons highroad et katia
tour d un mais tu vas food et 5 3 des 6
mai mais c'est pas clair franchement
c'est pas facile à gagner avec une
seconde à tour gilles tanqueray fuite
arrivée elle est tellement mal autant
par contre elle joue pas assez vite je
veux dire ouais dommages qui aura ses 4
a été peut-être plus du tout perdre en
temps elle menacée des trois-tours c2a
loi c-4 d'être je vais trois oui et
c'était c'était très chaud en réalité je
pense qu'elle est prête si elle a réussi
ça un peu près mouche puisque je crois
qu'ils allaient pas rapide à la souris à
l'oreille trois secondes contre trois
avec roy c4 en bullet quand on y met ses
b3 à b2 fouka tu vois c'est très facile
à jouer en fait avec les blancs tu tues
tu sais pas d'où ça va venir quoi est-ce
que le truc c'est quand il fait des
trois échecs tu sais que tu fais un
échec dont tu vas pouvoir reprenne move
en fait oui donc si tu as trois points
chacun avec toi tu peux jouer deux coups
d'affilée et que l'autre allait dans
l'expectative et peut-être même mieux
pas souvent c'est vrai ça je note dans
mon cahier pour une position de bullet
après roy c4 tu vois avec 3 secondes
chacun je sais pas si je prends les
blancs les noirs sûr j'en sais rien
c'est vraiment égale quoi et tu vois là
elle améliore s'arrêtant doit à peu près
dans
dans la partie magnus contre kerry king
oui précisons ils sont c'est à peu près
les mêmes plans je crois oui qu'elles
veulent et h2 faut protéger un s2
maintenant et là tu vois là latine jr a
pris le rythme là ça ya là le rythme
elle a le rythme dans la peau
regardez elle joue vraiment vite mes
cavaliers g4 c'est bien joué de
l'échangé ce cavalier à 9,6 donc je ne
sais pas oui mais voilà le rythme dans
la poêle à 20 secondes d'avancé à faire
b5 bekkat rallieront ensuite une manière
de bien
non mais 5 et 4 s'affaiblit trop la
structure je pense tu vois et si il faut
faire très attention et tu voi et réussi
à pousser des quatre au centre je ne
sais pas je viens j'aime bien cette
position là pour les blancs et les pas
si simple à jouer mais je pense qu'il en
soit elle se perd un peu la raison
elle avait le rythme dans la peau mais
en fait est que le rythme est là si je
prends donc un relief la richesse non
non je veux dire juste d'apprendre et
louis page et qu'après il ya que 4 mais
s'est échangé un cavalier c'est une tour
j'ai simcoe pour menacer cavaliers f4 ou
d'alger 6 7 et 6 sur ses juges y'a pas
ton point f2 car il prend ajouté pas en
dire autant
laraque et raya la tour en d'être en
l'air et chili a le rythme dans la peau
mais le coût au rachat encore c'était
pour éviter qu'un rallye et 4 après un
décalage et capte avec alger 4 à ce
moment là je demande à être ouais en
fait c'était à chaque fois je pense que
la position est mieux pour les blancs
mais à force de jouer ça c'est normal à
un moment donné que tu te prennes un
truc en fait mais quand un adversaire
s'adapte aux usa elle gagne la pièce
terrible au terrible d'un ghetto rien
d'avoir perdu la milliardaire est
normalement de 17ème
c'est normal je sais pas des toiles mais
tu verras jamais chaussé show denain est
un voilà la raison faut envoyer les
pions dams et 3b cas de toute façon mais
bon elle va vouloir jouer dame français
oui non des 4 as mais d'abord je
prendrai le pian jouer mais tant pis
c'est pas grave dame b3 la selas et
terminator annonce truc c'est que le
pion aux va trop vite va beaucoup trop
vite le plus bas des 5 4 ap temps non
ouais mais bon dame f77 c'est trop
facile ça c'est trop facile
mesdames et messieurs le tchèque adam
échec et mat
donc ça va faire quoi ça va faire deux
points d'écart 4 30a il reste deux
parties ont été en reste deux rim j'ai
obligé de gagner et les eaux mêlées dans
l'obligation de gagner les deux parties
du deux parties well conseiller pour
espérer un tie break donc délicate
on a vu ce cas de figure rien c'était
très intéressant
h3 tuyau elle change la gagnante aux
infos kalivia en moins de 90 coups par
contre 1,6 à 90 coups ça suffira pas
okal gaillon 80 coups même temps je dis
que gagne un topo mais par rapport à la
vague précédente je suis passé sur l
oblige à jeff 3 ça a pas l'air d'être
terrible terrible ans pour les blancs
franchement parce qu'il ya une mieux
mais bon en même temps oui tu veux tu
rejoues f4 et tueur et tombe dans les
positions en attendant elle est allée à
l'aise sur la wii
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un geste
c'est marrant parce que la partie elle
avait la partie contre le 5 mai s'est
approprié je crois que si je sais pas
s'il faut jouer vite je rejoins 5e même
temps et veut pas 5
voilà sa menace cavalli f5 ou cavale et
à chacun je pense à que je veux jouer
cinq qui ont tout et elle prend beaucoup
de temps moyenne obligé mais tu vois là
oui il a pris beaucoup de temps pourra
en cours mais en fait ça marche pas
parce que si elle prenait avait d'armes
français 5 et dans ce sens là y'a fou
prend 1,5
oui mais non mais pourquoi je pouvais
pas jouer parce que taïg khris et cinq
ans d'emprisonnement non je voulais
jouer cavalier 6 mai il y avait d'un des
six alors atk value si ce bien joué oui
fans terrible pour thing lie à la rate
et cavaliers aussi fallait faire food &
cie sûrement ou autre chose hélas elle
est complètement foutue très fier ouais
ménages et d'injustice dams et cinq noms
mais pour le moment qui ne menace pas
grand chose donc vaut mieux laisser le
quadrillage et c'est qu'il protège très
bien la position et dans le site c'est
très bien joué elle va essayer de le
flag et c5
oui bah si sur quelques jeux pour le
flingueur notre ami ya ding par notre
ami ben non c'est 5 dame prend des
citoyens mais il y avait 2 9 7 dans les
fuites matt annonce du coup elle a voulu
éviter l a obligé la tour était en prix
ça c'est typique aussi complètement et
là c'est terminé
ce sera oui fans contrarie cas c'est sûr
y aura pas il ya peu par une 46 peut pas
y avoir trois parties la cepap à
fabriquer le gagne deux parties ont eu
une minute 40 c'est mathématiquement
impossible
oui fans elle peut même partir là et
toujours rêver voir un joueur qu'on sait
comme ça comme les matchs durent
longtemps juste se levait partir et
prendre les deux points de pénalité de
chasse comme et gagner
non mais les points de pénalité 6 ans
nancy tu bizarre mais si tu te lèves
juste super par forfait en fait les
parties continuent à sa part y est mais
juste super mais j'ai toujours rêvé voir
sur czech comme quelqu'un qui regarde le
temps qu'ils voient qui reste une 40 et
qui c'est qui peut partir et dire merci
au revoir et à tu voulais voir ce
comportement irrévérencieux
je dois a complètement qui créera la
polémique je sais on en discutera
pendant des mois en rien
en révéler les râles et l'éthique des
joueurs au mieux ça qui carreaux qui
bouffent des salades pendant les matchs
qu enfin c'est un peu moi je suis un peu
dégueu j'ai jamais vue ils marchent
dessel a en fait il y à une pause de six
minutes en fait pendant la pause il se
fait sa salade qu'il a season
et pendant qu'ils jouent ils jouent en
bouffon de la salade quoi je trouve ça
un peu dégueu perso ouais c'est pas très
élégant
oui en même temps tu vas tu dis jusqu'à
où on peut aller dans la façon de se
montrer
c'est peut-être ça la vraie question non
mais non puis si le fait volontairement
il menait deux sets avant le bullet il
avait neuf points d'avancé sur
l'adversaire donc c'était complètement
terminée et en fait il n'a pas mangé la
semaine du coup il pouffe il pouvait se
permettre de ne pas manger quoi elle est
pas une fatigue il n'allait pas et enfin
il pouvait rien lui arriver le match
était déjà fini en réalité et ils
pouvaient manger pendant la pause quand
même oui et en fait on la pause tu vois
qu'il a tout préparé pour ouvrir sa
salade pour la commencer au moment du
début du match
évidemment ça fait pas sans quelques
copains ils voulaient mais lier son
adversaire oui oui mais j'aurais préféré
qu'ils se lèvent et qui partent plutôt
que de le voir beauf et sa salade
pendant 25 minutes quoi je suis
heureusement tu sais maintenant que tu
me racontes toutes ces histoires il ya
mes amis que me racontait que parfois
les gens stream leur façon de manger je
me suis dit cette culture culinaire
probablement des pays asiatiques je me
suis dit j'ai gardé une certaine
innocence encore même dans le streaming
je n'ai rien
c'est un truc la gagne à temps est ce
qu'il est un quoi il reste maintenant
c'est fini c'est fini en fait à c'est
fini d'accord je me suis dit peut-être
qu'il reste une dizaine d une poignée de
secondes dans la droiture et plus
continue est donc oui et fine gagne ce
match qui était très intense
wayne on attend sa tante en jeu bon
juste à thibault qui viennent mais elle
fait ça tu cryogénie vois pas du tout en
un mois tu sais bien enfin si les gens
on regarde mais streaming connaissent
ils savent bien que j'ai teint
systématiquement la caméra quand je
mange quoi pour moi c'est une question
d'éducation enfin je sais que mes
parents peuvent regarder et je sais que
mes parents elle n'en avait pas trop
voir beauf et à la caméra juste c'est ça
se fait pas quoi enfin c'est pas une
question de génie ou pas c'est une
question d'éducation après oui je pense
wesley encore une fois on a évoqué le
tour tu simplement question de voix de
d'élégance non ça ouais toute épreuve
on apprécie le match est serré que tu
manges quelque chose de sucré ou quoi
parce que tu as besoin pour pour
performer ça je le comprends en fait oui
moi aussi je peux pas pendant les
parties classées que seront les joueurs
mais ils sont plus le ton dos il avait
besoin de cet apport est obligé mais ça
du coup je le comprends travailler ou
maxime maxime pendant les matchs tu sais
il a un petit lit manger un petit peu il
a des fruits secs à côté ils mangent
pendant le match mais ça en fait j'ai
rien contre il est pas en train de se
faire une salade césar quand le match
est gagné à la caméra en mangeant et en
dansant en même temps qu enfin bon peu
importe c'est pas grave mais du coup je
veux dire qu il ya d aider un peu des
manques de respect pendant les matchs
moi j'aimerais bien voir injuste qui se
lève et qui par quoi qu'ils au gabon en
fait et huit dernières minutes j'en ai
même pas besoin je te laisse lui points
mais est ce que tu as envisagé que ça
peut se faire partie de peut-être du
personnage ces quelques facettes de ce
personnage ce grand public
bon je sais pas si on en actions entre
notre présence physique ou virtuel mais
voilà
mam et hikaru il avait clairement fait
pour vous ça fait parler un tu entends
parler surtout les streams en a parlé
sur twitter machin évidemment il a fait
ça pour faire le buzz mais mais j'aurais
préféré qu'il fasse le buzz juste voie
en se disant à dix minutes de la fin je
veux y mettre douze points d'écart et je
me barre j'aurais trouvé ça plus marrant
pour faire le buzz de faire un truc un
peu après c'était cool tu vois on en
parle encore maintenant et finalement il
a bien fait de le faire c'est du troll
mais bon je préfère du troll élégant que
du troll élégant
j'aime pas que les gens il est donc
j'écoute des mains se retrouve à la même
heure 36 à écouler sa taille favorite
pour demain oui fanou arica moi je mets
à ricard et là surprise
après avoir vu le match d hier les
matches d'aujourd'hui je pense que oui
la terre et quand j'ai regardé aussi un
peu les secours je serai là battu
alexandra kosteniuk hardcore et labatut
katrina d'haguenau fait maintenant j'ai
toutes les favorites en fait oui comment
donc j'ai pris en compte en fait toutes
les données je pense que areca oui et
part peut-être en légère favorite
merci amira d'avoir coûts commenté avec
moi et on se dit demain à 13h30
merci à tous cas ce que je vais faire
une partie contre la communauté
je veux faire une partie contre la
communauté non je me dis les pages sais
pas comment ça se passe et que leur fait
des blessés ça enfin on organise on
organisera sa mais on organisera sa sur
ma chaîne y aura plus de monde ce que
l'on en fait comme tu vois les gens
fuient un petit peu à cause de la pub
donc on n'est pas beaucoup de monde dans
le talon l'écart est ainsi mis
directement sur teichmann
non c'est comme ça que c'est pour ça
qu'on a beaucoup de pub et pas beaucoup
de personnes dans le chat en fait
d'accord d'accord mais il prend ça avec
beaucoup plus d'audience - ce sera plus
sympa d'accord pas je te remercie
beaucoup aidé à demain à demain merci
merci à toi lumière